hey good morning everybody and welcome
to environment agriculture we're going
to be getting underway
shortly and I'd like our members to take
their
seats and I would like um representative
H Haskins to please lead us in the
Pledge of
Allegiance I aliance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all I want to First welcome everybody
wish everybody a Happy Valentine's
Day and this morning we are going to
start
off with hb1
1221 relative to including Solid Waste
landfills in the definition and of
development of regional
impact
and have to be
official
I open our hearing for hb1
1221 and I'd like to introduce
representative Chuck grassy to introduce
this bill this morning thank you
representative grassy for coming and
take it away thank you madam chairperson
for the record my name is uh Chuck
grassy I'm state representative from W
for and Rochester New Hampshire um one
of the reasons why I introduced this
bill uh hb12
21 was throughout the last year I've
been working with a number of
environmental groups um on different
environmental issues and one of the
issues that always comes to the top is
new landfills in the state of New
Hampshire and what their impact is on
the communities that surround and
communities that are Downstream um
there's a concern about the public and
one of the the big things that they said
is that there's not enough opportunity
for input from the general public um and
I know there is a process which has
hearings uh which they have he but a lot
of people feel left out of the process
so I said one of the ways we can solve
this problem is make the make this a uh
make any new newly created landfill a
project of regional
impact and if those of you that have may
have served on planning boards in the
past know what a project of regional
impact happens in a community um the
application if it's declared a pro
Regional impact by the local planning
board it goes to the regional Planning
Commission they notify everybody uh
that's an abutter to that project every
town that's an abutter to that project
and they hold a hearing the information
provided at that hearing the testimony
taken is then sent back to the planning
board what we're looking at doing this
is a in a similar way that what would
happen is is that a a a new landfill
that was to be located in a County uh
whatever County they would in that
county would then have to notify what we
would consider a Butters and one of the
things we looked at is because the
science is
still the science is still not really
solid as far as groundwater is concerned
and the impact active landfills on
groundwater and all depends I mean we
have a and I will have to admit we have
a very good landfill in in the city of
Rochester and I know he's going to be
here testifying against this bill uh but
the thing is is that um how can you look
at communities are going to be impacted
and I looked at the maps and I said you
know if we took a look at it as far as
watersheds are
concerned that by identifying that any
Community within that Watershed and that
could be quite a few communities uh but
any community in that Watershed New
Hampshire has 18 different Weds by the
way um needs to be notified now they may
be Upstream they may be Downstream uh
they may be anywhere to the sides of
that if a landfill is located on the
edge of the Watershed I also put in a 20
mile buffer uh those communities know
more about their groundwater than
probably anybody else does because they
live in those communities and they work
in those communities they develop in
those communities if they are concerned
they will get involved
but a lot of times they aren't even
given the opportunity to in have input
um and this would require another just
another level of input the cost is quite
minimal um you know if a developer or an
applicant had to pay a couple thousand
dollars to notify a Butters um that's
not a lot of money when you're taking a
look at the projects that they're doing
when you're taking a look at the time
constraints yes that could be something
that could hold them up for 45 to 60
days uh while notifications are sting
out and and uh hearing is held and the
data is sent up to to the state um or to
the community and uh this is you know
this is just something that gives more
transparency into the process and I
think that it's something we really need
to uh to consider is the transparency
into the process uh this is something we
see most people are against now there
there is one error in the bill I checked
my notes and it wasn't my fault uh but
online six yeah uh it says RSA 33 colon
56 and it's supposed to be 36 I checked
my original notes what I sent over to
legislative services and I did have 36
there so it uh we didn't pick it up
until just this weekend okay uh but um
it it's something that needs to be
changed and I would also one of the
things that I know uh Waste Management
in Rochester will be here to testify on
is they think that this should apply to
newly to new applica applications for
new uh landfills and I would suggest a
wording that since we're going to change
30 six if you decide to support this
bill is it we should say all newly
proposed uh Solid Waste landfills uh
sell be projects of regional impact and
I'm I'm willing to accept that um I
think that it's something that uh we
could we could certainly uh we could
certainly live with and I would be happy
to answer any questions sure I have a
couple of questions right off the bat
um with your uh your suggestion for an
amendment for newly proposed landfills
um you would include you would not
include
expansions well I think that would be up
to the committee to take a look at I'm
not I I I don't necessarily think that
that needs to be in there because one of
the things that we have when there is a
landfill that's pre-existing we pretty
much know what's going on as far as the
groundwater's concerned um an expansion
would be on that same site and their
impact on the groundwater may not be
significantly different than what is
currently there so we should have an
indication of what's being impacted uh
whereas a new landfill you don't know
what's happening under the ground with
the aquifers and the groundwater um and
that's something when I in talking with
the regional planning commissions and
the Lakes Association um the concern was
is that pretty much anything Downstream
and in a watershed that's what you're
looking at things that are Downstream
but you never know because water
hydrology tends sometimes to do weird
things and we don't know that so that's
why included within 20 miles and also
anyone with in the Watershed now just
because you send a notification to a
community doesn't mean if they're well
away from the Watershed and they
personally feel they have no they're not
going to be impacted they just don't
respond um but it will give them the
opportunity to respond if they say Hey
you know we've got a large aquifer here
that's being impacted we have one in
Rochester an aquifer that's that's in
that's impacted from all the way up into
Farmington and into n Durham um and you
know we have to be concerned about that
that and it's a one that we now are
currently using for our wells and we're
finding that past is in it well where is
it coming from old Davidson rubber plant
was in the northern part of that area up
in the northern pot of Farmington and we
feel there may be some impact from a
dump site that they had 30 years ago 40
years ago okay um some my my second
question is um in lines three through
five of your bill
um I'm trying to figure out is that just
a clarification of what the above line
on number two because it already says
Solid Waste Disposal
facilities so why would that not include
any Solid Waste landfill requiring a
Department of Environmental Services
permit I mean aren't they all well this
here is putting it putting it into the
regional planning section of the
ordinances so basically they take
something out of another section of the
RSA stick it in here so that it
referenced a um we we wanted to Define
what would be con cons what would be
considered uh under uh Regional planning
because it puts it into the regional
planning statutes that's not currently
there I see and why did you choose on
line 11 20 miles that seems like a very
arbitrary number it it may be I mean we
have to have to pick out a number
somewhere and we what we wanted to do is
take a look at projects that may be
outside of a watershed but could be
impacted I mean one of the things you
have to consider that there also the
transportation of waste in and out of a
site uh and uh or and so 20 miles was a
number that was arbitrarily picked out U
the committee we're going to have to do
an amendment on this anyway so the
committee could arbitrarily change
it thank you very much represent Bixby
yeah so just a a question about the
mechanism of notification so the uh the
communities uh in within the scope
that's laid out in uh section three
Roman three would uh would the
notification go to the
municipal government in each of those
communities and it would be up to the
municipal government to provide any
notice to the town's people or City's
people yes that would be accur I mean
there would be notifications in in
papers of public interest and but also
uh the municipalities with the notice
would to be up to them to to basically
do anything more that they that they
wanted to but I would hope that as
Selectmen or U City Council Members that
they would that they would take it upon
themselves to get that out that they
reive this notification uh if anybody
has any information and they would like
to participate in the public hearing
they're welcome to go to the public
hearing and Testify the testifies would
held be held somewhere within that
county of the the regional planning
agency that was responsible but it could
cross over into other counties because
it's dealt with by Watershed and it
could also cross over into other states
because our watersheds are not confined
just within the state of New
Hampshire representative Howard thank
you madam chair um are you not concerned
about surface water why only groundw and
aers well I I am concerned about surface
water and when you deal with a watershed
you're concerned mostly with with
surface water but surface water gets
into the ground and one of the concerns
that I said use the entire Watershed
instead of just what's Downstream is
because subsurface water does strange
things and the hydrology may not act in
the same way that the surface water is
acting so when you say if you've got a
water shed and the land fill is in the
middle of that
Watershed and you can see that the water
is heading in a certain direction in a
southernly direction uh that is it or
following along a river such as the
marac river are those communities north
of it do they have any concern well you
don't know that's the thing we know
where the groundwaters the surface
water's going we know where that's going
and there's a lot of research that
allows us to do that we can figure that
out quite easily we don't know where the
where the subsurface water is going
that's why I included the whole
watershed
area follow up um so you know what water
is going but do you know what's in it
that I mean that's that's sort of our
concern is is when these surface waters
are are poisoned where where they go is
is secondary to that I think right yeah
well it it when the surface water is
poisoned you know that you have to be
concerned about the subsurface water and
I and and that's why I set the areas as
large as they were or within an within a
watershed because that surface water
will go will pretty much stay within
that
Watershed um and so so you have to be
concerned about what's happening to the
subsurface water as
well any other questions from the
committee representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question representative
um I'm wondering now how people are
notified um of an existing
landfill um and why people in
surrounding commun ities are not aware
and can't already come and testify they
do I mean communities that surround the
project are are notified and Dees and
I'm sure they'll be here to testify to
tell you what their notification process
is uh but they are notified but the
thing is this creates more people can
get involved it provides a l a larger
scope of involvement as far as people
who are notified and I think that's one
of the concerns it's just one more
public hearing that we will have uh you
know it's I don't look at this being an
onerous bill that's going to pile all
kinds of requirements on them it's a
relatively simple process and very
affordable process actually followup um
you also mentioned uh that we might be
noting uh some of these uh areas would
take into consideration other states
would then we also be notifying the
folks in other states according to this
Bill yes I would if it's within the
Watershed they should be notified and so
I see nothing wrong with it because they
could be impacted and they may want to
have input into into the bill um you
know if there was a bill put on the
southern part of the state it would
significantly impact Massachusetts
communities and or if it's put on the uh
you know around the Connecticut River it
could impact some Vermont Community
Water Supplies just having them giving
them the ability to come in and testify
um is pro you know is really no harm
what it does is it provides us with more
information because we have to look at
that our groundwater and our surface
surface waters are not confined to the
state of New Hampshire um we are
impacted by other states and I think
it's just curious of us to provide them
with the opportunity to have input when
we impact possibly impact their
groundwaters and their surface waters
one other followup thank you madam chair
um so are these other states uh
notifying us of anything that may impact
our state when it comes to watersheds
and surf ground subsurface I I I do not
know that ma'am and but I don't think
that makes really any
difference
okay that's a question probably for when
we hear from representatives from Dees
representative Murray thank you madam
chair and thank you uh to the sponsor
for taking my question um my question
was along this the the lines of whether
or not Watershed organizations
themselves might be notified if you're
if they are the entity that oftentimes
deals with the department they often
times deal with the public they're kind
of that
intermediary is there any intention to
actually notify those organizations I I
didn't put that in here that they would
have to be notified but going through
the regional planning commissions I
would assume that they would be U be
made aware of these hearings when
they're held um it's it's something that
um uh they uh I I dealt with this as a
regional planning issue rather than as a
you know any other way I figured this
was the the simplest way and we have
Regional planning agencies throughout
State and it was the simplest way to get
this out to the general public okay
representa B I just wanted to to clarify
something about something about the
scope in number three um so it's located
within any wed where there such a
landfill may be proposed uh and so that
if you're talking about say Lancaster
then that's a kinetic River Watershed so
if you just looked at that you'd say
well well are we going to have to like
notify people in Walpole and you know
Southern cheser County uh and then
Brattleboro uh but uh it looks like the
there's an and there so that it has to
be ALS it also has to be within 20 miles
is that correct uh no and the thing is
that one located within the Watershed
and located within 20 miles of the pro
it probably shouldn't have the end in
there because they're two different
things okay so in fact you would want
notification all the way to all of all
of the counties in Massachusetts and
Connecticut that are in the Connecticut
Valley Watershed that would
be uh because for for a project in
Lancaster well there it the watersheds
along the Connecticut River are divided
up into I see one two three four
different watersheds that um one of them
does go below the state of New Hampshire
the fifth one is pretty much out of it
so they wouldn't it wouldn't be
necessarily be the whole thing you'd
have to take a look at the Watershed map
that that Dees has and as I said there
are 18 different watersheds and the
connectica river is divided up into into
a number of different uh water sheds
okay so is that uh is there something in
statute that uh establishes those
watersheds as being um the entities that
are being looked at um
Dees has that information and that's
another thing that probably should be
done we should state that as watersheds
as defined by Dees okay and reference
their rules thank
you any other questions from the
committee represent comto thank you
madam chair um you just held up a nice
little Nifty U map uh is it possible to
get a copy for the file I will be happy
to give this to you thank
you any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much representative grassy thank you um
I'd like to call Katherine
query from the New Hampshire Sierra Club
good morning and welcome to environment
agriculture good morning thank you so
much um my name is Katherine Corry I'm
from New Hampshire Sierra Club and it's
great to be here in
Ena uh my first real committee that I
have um been able to participate in um
20 years ago so it's
great um happy anniversary
right um uh so uh New Hampshire Seer
Club represents about 12,000 people in
the state members and supporters and we
support the spirit of this bill um and I
too um wanted to suggest a friendly
Amendment uh to help Define who gets the
notice um I my suggestion for
uh Roman three was to perhaps um include
AB budding political
entities um so that we would get
Watershed District or um water and sewer
districts we could get downtown or
business districts school districts like
all of these different um components uh
to ensure that they got the notice about
these public
meetings
um I do that because I suggest that
because we're talking about Regional
impacts um that I that would go beyond
uh 20 miles you know some to some towns
um I was it it wasn't clear to me if
this was a 20 mile radius or if this is
20 mil along the road
um what did that mean and so I think
identifying um actual entities like a
sewage District Like a downtown district
or a school district uh would really
help um with the participation in in
transparency uh this is this is about
transparency and Regional impact and
uh with that I do support the bill um
and uh we'll take any
questions representative
NAB thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question are you aware if um
political entities are also notified for
any of the other Regional impacts um I
am aware uh that there are AB budding
towns um usually is how it's
identified um
and I have I I'm not going to know the
statute number but I have seen um that
definition before uh I can I can try to
I you know Wrangle that um ARA for
you represent
Murray um thank you madam chair and
thank you uh to that end I was I was
curious to know if something more along
the lines of I think uh Department of
Transportation
sometimes has political subdivisions
that that span across multiple entities
to notify of changes to Highway
Transportation plans or anything of the
sort is that what you were maybe
referring to I think that is I think
that is and and we there are Regional
sewage and water districts um that may
not be
captured exactly so I I and I think
that's really
important any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for
coming to speak with us this morning God
bless
you okay um Bria arvitson
good
morning good morning I'm Bria arbiton
program director of new Hampshire lakes
and I want to thank the chair and the
committee for the opportunity to speak
to you this morning on in our support of
HB
1221 New Hampshire Lakes represents over
275 local Lake Associations
committees communities I'm sorry and
over a thousand of new
Hamp excuse me this is my first
testimony you're doing great
congratulations take a breath we're good
good you're
fine so New Hampshire Lakes we represent
Lake Associations communities across New
Hampshire and also thousands of people
and individuals that support New
Hampshire Lakes as a Statewide nonprofit
organization we're dedicated to
restoring and protecting New Hampshire's
lakes and we believe that this bill is a
step in the right direction for the
protection of the lakes and we're
appreciative of the Watershed wide
approach where the whole dream area is
considered and also the people in it in
this type of
project whatever happens in the wed also
impacts our lakes or can impact our
lakes and thank you for hearing my
testimony and we urge you to recommend
this bill is ought to pass and I'll
gladly take any questions thank you any
questions from the
committee seeing none we want to thank
you very much and thank you you did
great uh um Stephen P
paggy py I'm sorry I didn't see the o
yeah
sorry morning Madame chair members of
the committee my name is Steve py I am
the director disposal operations for
Waste Management um in New Hampshire and
um just a little background on the
company um where the largest provider of
solid waste U Services in the country
and in New Hampshire we manage uh over
30% of the solid waste for the State of
New Hampshire we operate the turnkey
facility in uh Rochester and we have
four transfer stations and over uh 200
collection vehicles uh more than half of
those are currently running on natural
gas uh servicing our customers across
the state um so this experience and our
involvement and what's been going on in
the state mine personally over the last
30 plus years gives us a unique
perspective on this bill and um you know
the impacts that it would have have on
us and have on others uh we oppose the
bill is currently written um
HB
1221 uh we don't feel this is uh
necessary the permitting of a solid
waste facility such as the one in turn
key uh has an extensive lengthy process
uh in the permitting uh that's required
not only locally but at the state level
and uh at the federal
EPA um there's a technical review
process there's a public benefit
analysis that needs to be done uh
there's public notice there's public
comment uh and there's public hearings
that currently take place and that
notification goes out uh Statewide it's
published in the local paper it's
published in the Manchester Union leader
and the agency uh Dees does a good job
you know getting that word out so
letting folks know those public hearings
are taking
place um in the most recent um expansion
that we did at the turnkey facility it
took us over six years to get the permit
under the current uh regulations and
this bill I think would extend that
further and really make it difficult to
continue operating be beyond what we
currently have permitted at that site
the first provision in the bill uh talks
about that uh all communities within the
Watershed uh need to be notified the
current permitting process that is
already in place is that the applicant
needs to uh notify the New Hampshire
Rivers coordinator for the dees and they
in turn reach out to the affected River
advisory committees they're given notice
of the project and where it is what the
extent of that is and you know
that they need to sign off if you will
that they have a concern or they don't
have a concern if they do they weigh in
from a public comment standpoint or you
know our present at the public
meetings um and as a result of that we
feel this is not you know an additional
necessary step that needs to take place
relative to uh the river potential
impacts uh the second Vision regarding
notifications within a 20m radius uh we
feel this is excessive uh We've looked
at it at our
facility and it
reaches uh up to Lake wiip
Northampton uh Candia shapley main Kenny
bunkport and it's a it's a pretty
significant area I'm just a quick Google
Maps you can't see this I know but um I
can leave this with you it shows a
pretty EX extensive uh review and
concern that we have is um you if we
need to weigh everyone's concerns within
a 20 milei radius or anyone else getting
uh a permit to develop you know a new or
an existing facility continue to be
expanded is going to be extremely
difficult um we currently notice right
now um not only the uh folks that are
Butters to the parcel on which the
development is going to take place but
we go out to the limits of our property
uh we own about 1500 Acres at that
location in Rochester and notification
goes out to town of barington and the
City of so they're notified as well AB
budding municipalities and they have
opportunity to weigh in um you know at
the public hearing or provide comments
to the the New Hampshire uh Dees as part
of the
process um
you know we we take our relationship
with the host Community very seriously
um and we feel that this bill would
expand considerably those folks that may
or may not have impacts as a result of
the you know existing operation um if
there's issues at the site we will take
you know whatever steps are necessary to
address those and again concerning uh
neighboring municipalities we do the
same there as well we don't reach out to
folks that are 20 miles away from the
facility uh if there's a concern
obviously um we'd be happy to address
any issues that they may have uh at any
level or any you know steps along the
way so um those are my comments if um
folks have any questions be happy to
answer
them thank you Mr POI um so I'm
interested to know how do you notify
folks current L okay so we have to look
at our property if we have a
parcel uh that's in the middle or just
you know we go to the limits of our
property ownership so we currently go to
all the ab Butters that touch our
property and we notify them uh in our
case we are close to the do and
barington Town Line so we reach into
those communities as well uh we know
notify uh the city and Public Notices go
out um you know through the the papers
uh as well so there's a number of
different notification processes that
take place are they done in the
newspaper VIA mail via email via what
are what are the ways Billboards I mean
I don't know no they're done certified
mail uh return receipt requested so we
need to make sure that we get all those
back the state checks to make sure that
those notices are received um and if not
we have to chase people down sometimes
folks own property and they live in
California we've had a couple of those
over the years um so they need to get
that returned to us and then uh from a
public hearing standpoint um the state
well we put it out but the state
administers it notifications in the
local paper and Statewide distribution
um so it's done a number of different
ways and so in your testimony you
mentioned that by
expanding um the area by which you would
have to do
notification that it would cause
difficulty what kind of difficulty would
that ensue we've had we've had
discussions uh with municipalities that
have indicated they've got trucks
driving through their Community it's all
on state highways in our case but
nonethe less driving through their
communities and they feel they should
participate in the host Community uh
agreement that we have with the city of
Rochester we pay
Rochester over $4 million a year in a
variety of different host fees we
provide uh free disposal csite
collection a host per you know feet per
ton and if we've got a variety of
different communities weighing in and
wanting a piece of that it's going to
make it more difficult for us to
negotiate 15 20 different host Community
agreements because they feel they're
being impacted in some way okay
representative Bixby yeah so just to
follow up on that does this bill
establish those notice other notice
communities as host communities or does
it just require notice for they for them
to be able to attend a a public hearing
we interpreted just requiring notice
okay so so in fact there wouldn't be any
any sort of basis in law if this bill
went through for them to request to have
any sort of host Community
status that that's our interpretation I
I do know that we've had experiences
over years not at this facility in
particular but at another
location um that their objections would
be removed if there was a host community
agreement for our
municipality different site different
state but uh that's a concern that we
would have thank you okay representative
kraton thank you madam chair and thank
you for your
testimony so the the way the bill reads
and the way your your map U was
diagrammed was that you have TurnKey for
example and then you have a 20 mile
radius or diameter all the way around in
a circle that's including upstream and
downstream that's correct would that uh
would it would your analysis be
different if it was only
Downstream with the assumption that
water primarily is going to flow
downhill yeah the the bill currently
States quote located within 20 miles of
such a proposed landfill location and
our interpretation is a 20 mile
radius for a followup followup so if if
the bill for for example said down
stream as opposed to radius would how
much do you think that would change your
analysis well it would reduce the 20
mile notification um requirement
obviously um but Downstream I think
representative bck spe brought up a good
point uh if you've got a site and you're
you
know Watershed flows down the
Connecticut River for example it goes
through adjoining States you'd be
notifying folks all the way down to
Connecticut Massachusetts I don't think
that's really intent of Representative
Bry but you know that could be
interpreted that
way okay represent Murray thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question I just wanted to clarify when
you're talking about those who are
notified via certified mail those are
only direct abutters is that correct uh
that's correct um I believe we notify
adjoining municipalities also
representative H Haskins and then NAB
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so we're talking
about Regional impact here right and
we've heard testimony that the water
goes where the water wants to go so if
outlying communities are going to be
impacted but they're not a
Butters shouldn't we be concerned about
those communities having agency and
that's my first
question and the second question is
Dees has a lot on their plate so
notifying the rivers
Association may not get the kind of um
response or the kind of scope that we're
thinking about in terms of regional
impact so what are your thoughts about
that okay couple couple things uh
relative to the
de's
um responsibilities or what they've got
on their plate um this would I believe
expand that considerably um you will
have a lot more folks weighing in um and
the state will have to State the dees
will will be expanding the review
process um to include towns 20 m miles
away that will add additional workload I
believe on the agency to address those
questions to your first question
relative to uh impacts uh there are
requirements uh in the permitting uh and
uh operation uh requirements for the
site for any site to have groundwater
monitoring Wells within close proximity
to the footprint uh surface water
sampling uh that information is uh
collected uh Prov Prov to the state's
public information uh so before it gets
to a river um folks are going to know
about it ahead of time and be able to
put actions in place quick followup if I
may sure thank you um I don't think it's
the Bill's intent to put on to
Dees any more of this work we're talking
about the permite having the
responsibility of getting this
information to outling communities that
are going to be impacted that don't seem
to currently fall under the RSA for
abutters and so forth Just understood
yes thank you representative NAB and
then Bixby thank you madam chair thank
you for being here um so I think it's
great that there's notification to the
local River advisory committees but it's
my understanding that those are
volunteer committees made up with from
representatives from each town along the
River so do you see a benefit in having
a response come from actual Town
staff that are impacted by the River or
abing the river I I think that's fine
they want to notify Downstream
communities okay thank you just before
representative Bixby I know that
representative kraton um is a volunteer
on one of those committees right uh I
think everything we do is volunteer
except for the $100 a year we get paid
um no I am on the Kentuck North Branch
River Community and it includes towns
that
start uh Ren Jaffrey almost all the way
to conquer and uh we meet once a month
we are we are appointed by the town
there are normally two members per town
and anything that
impacts the KCK North Branch Rivers
which is what we're responsible for for
and that includes building permits that
includes for example town of antram just
upgraded their water system uh and so we
go to the site we get with Dees we talk
to local Representatives as in like
Selectmen but also people are budding
those those activities and then we are
uh required to sign off on those
projects and we look at probably
two to three projects a month um that
impact those rivers and it's all the to
all the towns have to tap to chop off on
it so a major landfill going in would be
a significant uh event the president of
our
committee uh is an engineer with
hydrological
background represent vix you had a
question yes so um if uh if the bill
were amended to uh create a grandfather
clause for existing landfills that are
uh see that are seeking expansions would
you be more comfortable with the bill we
would
yes
okay representative
Howard thank you madam chair um I these
notifications that you send out now are
they all mandated by the state yes
um so so a less scrupulous company would
still have to fulfill those same
notification requirements that's correct
thank you any other
questions thank you very much thank you
appreciate you answering all our
questions like to Now call Michael norc
from New Hampshire
Dees
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee uh for the record
Michael Nor I'm here representing New
Hampshire Dees uh I'm in the solid waste
management
Bureau uh I think the sponsor did a
pretty good job of outlining what the
scope of this bill would be uh but I
just want to reiterate that as we read
it as as this bill is introduced um this
would govern the local planning use
board uh notification and hearing
process as outlined in RSA
36 uh there's been a lot of testimony
and conversation around de's
notification requirements for the
permitting the state permitting process
which is separate and distinct from the
local planning use board or planning
board um process for uh in notifying um
and so this this bill would only kick in
if a local planning board receives an
appliation for development of a
landfill um so I just wanted to just
clarify that for the record that is our
understanding of what this bill's scope
would be um and DS is not taking a
position on this bill however we do we
just wanted to be here to present some
concerns relative to how we read this
bill uh what it's ex the extent of its
uh notification requirements might be
and how that might impact local planning
use boards uh as was noted there would
be uh a 20 M radius requirement so if
the landfill is proposed in a given town
uh there would need to be notice given
to surrounding communities within 20
miles on all sides uh and that would
exist that requirement for not
notification would exist over and above
a requirement for notifying communities
also within the same Watershed as the
proposed
landfill um one of the challenges with
the way the bill is written is it
doesn't
Define what watered is I think the
committee has already kind of clued into
that um and depending on how you define
the extent of a watershed it could
Encompass hundreds of communities across
state borders I mean the Connecticut
River Watershed goes all the way down to
Long Island Sound um so you know you can
you can and I'm not an expert on um
hydrogeology or how watersheds are are
delineated in the state I noted that uh
uh Mr Podi had a map that Dees has has
developed that's a separate section of
Dees so I can't really speak to that but
I do know that there are different uh
kind of subsets within uh watersheds so
there's greater watersheds kind of at a
macro scale and then they're kind of
broken down into smaller pieces as well
and that's shown on that map um and uh
so so the bill doesn't really provide
Clarity on what the extent of the
Watershed would be um and we just think
that they're again we don't take a
position we don't necessarily OS this
that we're all for transparency on all
levels um but we do have concerns on how
a local planning board might be able to
determine compliance with the
requirements here and and make
notifications as required um so I just
wanted to to state that for the record
I'm happy to take any questions
representative
kraton uh thank you madam chair thank
you again so the way you read this then
does any one of these 100 towns I'm
throwing that out there as you draw a
circle that's 20 miles in
radius does each one of those have a
veto power or what I mean so you notify
them then can they say okay well we
don't want this you can't have it is
that I mean what what is the power of
that town once notified that's a good
question thank you representative Katon
I think as we read it um it's
essentially a notification requirement
to notify surrounding communities that
may be impact Ed um to allow them to
provide input at a hearing process you
know the local planning board's uh you
know hearing for the application that
they receive for the landfill okay so I
don't think that they necessarily have a
veto power but they have the opportunity
to provide input okay thank
you representative H Haskins and then
NAB thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question I'd like to hear
a little bit more about the planning use
board could you describe what that is De
it would only take effect if local
planning board gets a notice I'm trying
to follow that thank you for the
question this this is not necessarily
within
DS's area of expertise or or something
that we necessarily govern or regulate
this is the so when I referred to local
planning use boards uh it's essentially
a town or jurisdiction or a district
that uh has
planning uh kind of uh Authority or
responsibility for a given jurisdiction
they would have to provide local
approval for a development project in
this case we're talking about Solid
Waste landfill um so I think what this
bill would aim to do is to enable
those it would it would essentially
Define landfills as a project that would
have Regional impact it would take away
the the need for them to make that
determination mhm and it would then uh
require them to notify communities as
defined within the 20 mile radius and
also within the Watershed so again it
just governs the local approval process
and the notification requirements
associated with that quick followup as I
may and and we're talking about
notification we're not talking about
agency we're not talking about voting
we're just talking about notification
and transparency being the goal
notification it would appear should be
part of that no I believe you're correct
I think that that's in line with our
reading of the bill it's about
notification transparency which on its
face sounds uh reasonable uh we just
have concerns about the extent to which
municipalities may need to to the the
essentially the reach of the
notifications understood thank you
representative NAB and then
representative Bixby thank you madam
chair um I also have concerns about how
broad the 20 mile radius is and if it's
a little bit arbitrary I know you're not
a hydrologist but do you have any
thoughts about what more appropriate
distance would be I um like you I can't
really say what would be more
appropriate um I I think it's just a
question of what is reasonable for the
given project and and I can't say for
sure what that would
be followup do you have any suggestions
at getting at a different
number um nothing concrete at this at
this time I'm sorry okay pres viby uh
representative nav just asked my
question
okay I've been wondering that as well
any other questions from the
committee thank you I appreciate your uh
you're coming to speak with us is there
anyone else uh in the room I have no
more pink cards so anyone else wish to
speak on
this I'll need a pink card after you
speak please rep and introduce yourself
again yeah my name is Wayne Morrison I'm
with North Country Alliance for balance
change I hadn't intended to speak today
so I don't I don't have written
testimony or anything um I just want to
um encourage the
committee um these bills we often get
wrapped up in the complexity of the bill
and we we get into minutia and I I
recognize that the committee
responsibility is to have a bill that
the language is clear and it's and it's
something that can be
enacted but the purpose of the bill to
to as I read it was the recognition
that um the physical spot where a
landfill is
located the plot of land and that
town um is a is a is a minor piece of
the people that are impacted by a
landfill
and whether it's noise or smell or
traffic the actual impact area of a
landfill is fairly large and I I applaud
the bill for recognizing
that people that are going to be
impacted should have a
voice I would also want the committee as
somebody who has been actively involved
in this for the last four or five
years without being a iepc I can tell
you that having a voice and taking the
time and energy to come and make your
feelings and your concerns
known often feels like you're you're
talking into the
wind there's no
feedback um it often feels like you know
it's merely an exercise a box to be
checked off that you had a a public
hearing and I I would encourage the
committee to to kind of push through
some of these issues but the the bigger
issue to me is recognizing how impactful
landfills are and I I'll give you a
quick example my wife and I own property
on Forest Lake if you drew a line down
the middle of forest lake half the lake
is in the town of Dalton and half the
lake is in the town of
Whitefield I I am not one here uh
looking to tap into the host agreement
um I'm I'm happy to pay my
taxes but I am going to be far more
impacted in Whitefield than the people
in Dalton just because physically where
that landfill would be
located and I don't feel as a citizen
that I'm really being given the type of
voice that I should have to say my my my
property values my quality of life is
going to be tremendously impacted and I
think that's true of Littleton and
Bethlehem and I don't know about a 20
mile Zone I I I haven't done any I I
understand there's some Logistics to
this and I don't this this is a
complicated process I I get that if I
were you I would eliminate the existing
landfills and I would I think we should
focus on the go forward and apply it to
New landfills but this is something
worth doing and it's a a real impact and
I think that the committee should not
disregard this or drop it because of
complexity we should simplify it to the
extent we can and I think the overriding
principle is not how do we make this
easier for Dees or easier for the
applicant how do we make this more effed
effective for the people that are going
to be impacted by these these landfills
and I would I would just I guess I would
just ask you not to give up on this bill
I think it's there's some there's some
Merit here and as a citizen um and I
think you know representative kryon as
you as you talked about this and you
said you know you asked some you know
questions um you know I I I do think
that it's you know there there's real
power in giving people a voice and um I
don't think that's the case today I I I
you know
there's this landfill that's keeps
coming up in Dalton there's n 900 people
in
Dalton um I think of this as the impact
zone is much bigger than that um and if
we just focus on this little Community
yes that's more manageable
um and that that is physically where the
landfill is going to be but that is in
no way the the impact um area that is
going to affect many many more people
and uh livelihoods and businesses and I
just I would encourage you to uh Wade
through this and and find a way to come
up with it making this bill
appropriate so I have a question for you
with regard
to I'm sure that with and then I don't
want I don't really want to get into
like specifics per se but there have
been hearings I'm imagining in the
Dalton
area what community of people do you
feel did not have a voice and how did
they not have a voice in the current
process um I think the people who have a
voice are people like myself who have
become very active in this but I think a
lot of other people um I I think one of
the problems is people think that if the
landfill isn't in their backyard it
doesn't affect them I don't know about
the notice process I mean I can tell you
that every public hearing that I have
gone to and and and one of them that
went on for I don't know six or seven
hours of people one after another
getting up and describing why they don't
want a
landfill um I I'm not sure that that
process is all that effective and I
don't I'm not sure anyone's
listening um I don't know if that's the
best vehicle um that it has no meat I
mean I I think the idea of allowing
people making it transparent and giving
people a voice is important but you
didn't have any kind of situation where
um you went to a meeting and they said
well you live in Whitefield so we we
don't really want to listen to what you
have to say yeah no no uh we we we we
had a voice um but the the mechanisms
and
the um the the the way that the process
works um planning boards select boards
um I think if you're not in the host
Community you are you're
marginalized you don't have the same
voice commensurate with the impact that
you are going to
face and I don't know if I'm being clear
about that but I yes there's
notification I think I think the bigger
issue
is make my voice meaningful give it
weight don't just make it a formality
don't make it yes we had the public
hearing
check I I don't even think and and I
look I respect Dees they have a very
difficult
job but we don't even get feedback we
don't get we disagree with your voice
with what you said we don't say that's a
great idea we get nothing we get we get
silence and that's very
demoralizing uh to people that take the
time and energy and effort and put their
heart and soul into trying to protect
their
Homestead and there's things there's
just things that are wrong so I I only
step forward and again I I I I haven't
prepared comments for this but um you
know I I think I think the I think the
logical thing is to focus this on new
landfills and to think about the intent
of the bill which is to make sure people
who are going to be impacted actually
have a say in what
happens okay thank you representative H
Haskins and then representative M chair
and and thank you for taking my question
so I think what I understand from what
you're saying is that if let's say the
applicant was asked to come to a
planning board meeting that's not Dalton
for instance they can choose not to come
right so is that not a loophole in the
system when you're trying to get your
voice
heard yeah I mean I I think at the end
of the
day
businesses do what they are told to do
so if the law says you have to meet with
the Dalton select board then you meet
with the do Dalton select board and to
the extent that they are not forced to
do that they will not do do that either
um what I'm saying is these are these
are Big impactful
projects and it's not good what we're
doing today is lacking in terms of the
voice and the commensurate opportunity
to um have a say in what's really going
to be very impactful to your town to
your property to your quality of life
and I think that's what the bill is
intended to do I I you know I think
there's there's amendments or there's
changes that need to be made I'm just
encouraging you to to don't give up on
it it's it's something that's worthwhile
and meaningful to Citizens thank you
representative H Haskin uh Howard I'm
sorry thank you madam chair and I'm so
glad you came in today Mr Morrison
because I think that um you have pointed
out the biggest weakness in this bill
which is you get a hearing but do you
really have influence does it is there
are they is this a promise of of results
from your hearing um I it seems to me
that there's a possibility that you know
hundreds of people could come from all
over the region from the whole Watershed
and have their voices heard and not have
anything happen as a
result do you agree with me yeah I I I I
think I think I don't want to be I don't
want to be negative I think a lot of
these things are well intended but I
don't think I don't think we want please
don't put any more bureaucracy in place
don't don't make it a formality don't
ask waste companies to have a meeting if
it's not really going to accomplish
anything but I do think as a citizen and
having been involved in in this thing
these are Big projects big impact long
range uh you know it doesn't go away in
a week or a month or a year you're
living with this for decades so giving
people and surrounding towns that are
going to be significantly impacted for
this they should have a a strong voice
and somehow or other they they the
impacts that they're feeling should be
part of the decision process about
whether the project goes forward or not
and I think it's far broader than that
plot of land that physical you know
piece of a town where it's going to sit
um New Hampshire is a small
State uh you know acre landfill doesn't
just affect this the one town it sits in
it it affects a far broader group of
people
so represent Bixby yeah so um you said
that uh that as as a resident of
Whitefield uh you received notices of
the meetings and I would assume that
people in Bethlehem would also have
received notice I'm wondering about uh
where people who were two or three towns
uh Downstream or upstream and I I don't
know the I don't know the the geography
of that particular area so I can't name
particular towns but are were people who
were two or three towns away but uh
still within the Watershed uh or within
say a 10 15 mile radius getting notices
or were those towns getting notices or
was it just the immediately abing towns
yeah I I'm going to plead ignorance I I
I can't in truth answer that completely
I know that the surrounding towns uh
were aware of the meeting and and showed
up in droves but how far that periphery
went I I couldn't tell you and I also
the the complexity of this too
is um Dees doesn't deal in traffic
issues for example that's the Department
of
Transportation
so just I don't mean to take up a lot of
your time when you when we think about
the proposal in in Dalton that's 100
trash Halls 100 trucks in and out of
little New Hampshire towns that you know
that are not built for those kind of
vehicles going through little you know
uh intersections and so even though
you're you're not uh you know the the
dees control of the I don't know the the
the science and the and the toxins and
the leade and all the rest of it there
are other extenuating circumstances that
impact towns Whitefield is a I don't
know 2500 people um it's a rural town
and you know as people think about big
trash hallers making sharp turns and
going into and out of the
landfill that's going to have a really
big
impact and um you know I'm not
sure that in the way in the in the
decision process of yes or no from Dees
how does that get weighed in I don't
think it
does representative H
Haskins Mr Morrison thank you madam
chair why did you form the North Country
Alliance for balanced
change um the truth is the the the
organization that I'm now president of
was started about uh almost 15 years ago
and it started with a different land use
um I don't know how much detail we
should get into but um somebody wanted
to do something with a big track of land
actually the same land now that's being
considered for a landfill was going to
be a drag strip and if you group of
homeowners got together and said wow TR
sound travels far and fast um what does
that really mean so the group kind of
started with the idea and by the way
we're not just about trying to kill
projects we're trying to promote
positive things for you know we recently
were actively supporting um a solar
project for homeowners in the North
Country to be able to kind of band
together and you know so we're we're
trying to balance the economic interests
and and the Environmental Protections
that we think are critical to in the
North Country it's all about tourism
that drives most of our industry most of
our
livelihoods so we started to protect
that and U so as we've gotten more
involved we've gotten a you know this is
the last place I ever thought I'd be
sitting you and as I retired from work
to be sitting in front of the
environment and agriculture committee
talking about solid waste because I knew
nothing about it and um you know five
years in it's all different well we
thank you for coming um hope you uh do
fill out a pink card yeah I will to give
our Clerk and I'm going to ask if there
is anyone else who wishes to speak on
this
bill uh one in the
back Mr Tut Hill good morning and good
morning
we need your pink card too I'll give
it thank
you um thank you Madame chair members of
the committee my name is John tutill I'm
from aworth um just very very briefly uh
listening to this discussion I think one
important piece here is to consider the
role of planning boards zoning boards of
adjustment and just the general planning
process in small
communities um I think that once you get
a designation of uh development of
regional impact at that point you've got
the support of regional planning
commissions or I think in the north it
would be the North Country Council they
have resources they have some expertise
in terms of the transportation issues um
so I would strongly urge passage of this
bill and I think it is a good idea
perhaps to simplify it but just provide
this extra opportunity for ab budding
communities to participate in a formal
process through the planning boards
thank you thank you any
questions seeing none anyone else who
wishes to
speak okay we have the blue sheet
here um okay so uh the online portal
have
37 persons in favor of the bill and one
against and on our blue sheet we have
one two three six seven seven people in
favor of the
bill and one
neutral and with that I'm going to close
out the hearing for HB
1221 and I know we're running a little
late but I will open up the hearing for
hb1
1490 relative to the solid waste
management
act and I invite uh representative eel
to come in introduce her bill to our
committee good morning representative
evil good morning Madam chair always
good to see you again um for the record
my name is Karen Eble I represent mayor
ma district 7 and uh that is the towns
of New London and Newbury uh my
introduction of this bill is going to be
very brief this morning it's hb1
1490 I introduced the bill on behalf of
the
department and it's basically as they um
as their letter in support of the bill
explains it's basically cleaning up and
clarifying some definitions that uh
requir doing that um and they really are
the best folks to speak to the text of
the bill and what they were trying to
accomplish so um I'm happy to answer
questions but honestly I think they are
really the best ones to direct your
questions to thank thank you any
questions no when we will have leam
McKenna come and speak on this Bill
thank you representative
evil good morning Miss
McKenna
good morning Madam chair members of the
council for the record my name is Leah
McKenna and I am the administrator of
the solid waste management Bureau at the
Department of Environmental Services
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today um on
1490 as representative eel stated this
was a bill that was uh proposed by the
department and it is indeed to intended
to clarify a number of well for uh items
that are currently in the solid was
statute 149
M so I'm going to take a couple of
minutes now to explain each of those
four
items first the bill seeks to amend the
existing statutory definition of a
butter currently that definition is any
person who owns property adjacent to or
across a road railroad or stream from
the property on which a solid waste
facility may be permitted
so in a butter used in the context of
the statute and the administrative rules
uh is afforded a number of notifications
for a number of steps that are involved
in the permitting process landfills
transfer stations um recycling
facilities
compost um so for example one of those
notifications might be an applicant
wishing to propose a new solid waste
facility they're required by rule to
notify a Butters of certain information
about that facility um another example
is the requirement to not notify a
Butters of any public hearing that's
required by Statute or rule so we
believe that amending the existing
definition to include Property Owners
located across a utility Corridor or a
water course would allow for more
inclusivity for the universe of parties
who receive these notifications and can
then decide whether or not they want to
participate in the process of public
hearings next the bill would clarify the
existing definition of endof Life motor
vehicle and that would be by stating
that the term motor vehicle is as
defined in RSA
25960 which is the state's motor vehicle
statute third the bill provides explicit
Authority currently for or I apologize
the proposed Bill provides explicit
Authority for Dees to terminate permits
when a facility closes the facility and
no longer intends to conduct the
permitted
activity right now the statute provides
that permits are continuous in duration
and that presents a challenge to us when
a facility physically closes they cease
all activity but yet the permit by
Statute is considered continuous in in
duration what we're hoping is this will
this will provide us an ability to to
formally terminate a permit without
having to go through a suspension or
revocation process which is really not
needed in in these
cases and then lastly the bill corrects
a drafting error dating back to the 2019
legislative session which was part of uh
Senate Bill 163
that bill amended timelines for review
of solid waste permit applications in
RSA 149 M9 Roman 8 but the bill failed
to amend the corresponding language in
RSA 149 M12 Roman 3 to reflect this
change so this amendment just corrects
that
Omission that's what I have for you at
the T at this moment uh thank you very
much for allowing us to provide
testimony and I'm happy to answer any
questions representative Bixby yeah so
under the current Cent uh uh wording of
stream uh I'm going to just use an examp
um Waste Management in TurnKey as an
example so uh their Pro their property
goes up to the ice and glass river right
would someone under current under the
current uh phrasing would someone who
was across the ice and glass River be
not considered in a butter correct
because that would be because right now
what it has in our unnecessarily
narrowed to stream only and so an
applicant can say the Isen glass river
is not a stream therefore um we know we
wouldn't consider them in a butter so
this is this is meant meant to increase
um that from from a stream to a river a
canal uh another another form of a
channel thank you
sure any other questions from the
committee represent Duty just um the
word water course is one word and and
I'm not familiar with that word it's not
supposed to be two words I've seen it
I've seen it both way okay and a water
course just means any type of water
water water running through a channel
okay yeah thank you it's not not not the
not Lake Waki okay water running through
a channel okay thank you
sure any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank
you and I wonder from the committee
seeing as this is pretty straightforward
um cleanup language of the
statutes I wonder if there is any
objection for us to even uh consider
executing this bill at this time
representative Bixby I would be in favor
of executing it s
OTP we need to close out this yeah right
I'm not I'm not moving that I'm just
saying that I would be willing to
execute so that just clarify that so let
me get the blue sheet uh for this bill
since there any other folks that would
like to speak on this represent um sorry
Mr
POI
St Steve py with Waste Management y I'm
uh we don't hold a position on this bill
I just want to clarify something that
was exchanged earlier um we do notify
folks that are cross the river we've
done that for over 20 years that is our
interpretation of an a butter I think
the rule clarification makes that
clearer um I can see where someone may
argue that someone's an aob butter in
that case but we've been doing that for
for many years so that's all I have
thank you for your additional comment
appreciate it any any questions for Mr
POI seeing none thank you um so I have
the blue sheet for
this there there's um online 18 in
support one oppos one opposed on our
blue sheet there's six persons uh in
favor of this spell and I will close out
the hearing for hb1
1490 and I
would again same day um so if there's no
objection we can exec this bill uh would
anybody like to make a motion um give a
minut oh sure give give Barbara a minute
uh representative ktoa I'm sorry pardon
me okay uh I would like to move a to
pass on HB
1490 representative Katon seconds would
you like to speak to your motion
uh I think that uh the department
explained pretty clearly why these uh
small changes to law are sensible and
necessary and I think we should just do
it now
okay I would um request the clerk caller
all
then thank you madam chair uh we're
voting OTP on House Bill 1490
representative kraton hi representative
coma yes representative Davis yes
representative kulon yes representative
Penza yes representative
smart represent Bixby yes represent Duty
yes represent Murray yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard yes represent
NAB yes madame chair
yes 130
motion uh passes uh consent would anyone
object to consent I think consent makes
sense consent makes sense all right
um so I guess we've run early today and
[Music]
um
if if everybody is fine we can um take a
break till
1:00 and uh we'll see you
then thank you
evil
okay we'll get underway
shortly
thank you not too many
no all
right as everybody gets their pink slips
in
soon
okay okay hang
on
okay good afternoon welcome to
environment agriculture everybody and I
am going to open up our hearing for HB
11:45 all our members have taken their
seats and uh to introduce this bill we
have the esteemed representative Peter
Bixby thank you madam chair uh for the
record I'm Peter Bixby straford District
uh representing portions of Dover uh and
uh
so uh this bill uh I I put this bill in
initially because I thought that
something like this needed to go in and
I was hoping that a more extensive bill
would come out of the um the uh study
committee on unlimited service areas and
out of state waste uh the main purpose
my main motivation for bringing this
bill is uh because New Hampshire
landfills get an awful lot of
uh of waste from out of state and uh for
the landfills that are privately owned
uh there is
um the uh current a fairly standard
interpretation of the law is that the
state cannot limit uh the how much of of
that out ofate waste they choose to uh
take uh as long as the if the
limitations are not exactly the same
between instate and out of state waste
uh and it occurred to me that the key
problem was that we have uh um private
landfills that we just can't control how
much of that of the outstate waste is
coming in if we moved our our landfills
to being public then we would have
complete control over that so for
instance nashaa and Lebanon uh do not
have to take any uh waste from out of
state because they are entirely
controlled by those
municipalities uh they can choose to I
believe that Lebanon takes some waste
from uh communities just across the the
Vermont border uh so the basic idea is
that uh Land by making landfills in the
state public we would be able to control
the out of state waste and
uh so um the study committee came back
and said we really like your bill we
think it makes a lot of sense so let's
just go let it go in like that but we we
have a couple of suggestions uh and uh
actually one of these suggestions was
something I I'd also thought of which is
that we wanted to make sure that we
grandfathered existing private landfills
because um we we don't want to uh put um
TurnKey out of business for instance um
so uh there is a uh fairly there there
the grandfathering Clause is basically
what we have prepared for some other
bills and we discussed that with uh uh
with uh a representative from TurnKey so
we know that that is something that
would cover private landfills fairly
effectively
uh the
other um the other thing that was
suggested was that for uh landfills that
are owned by the state it would make
sense to require that those be managed
and operated by a private business uh so
that the state would not be in the
business of figuring out how to run a
landfill they would be uh they would
have the ownership but not the
operational require um uh
responsibilities and they would simply
oversee those they would oversee the
operation but they would not uh be in
charge of the
operation uh
so uh so that's basically what the bill
does uh it oh and for the municipal and
county level uh the the subdivisions can
choose whether they want to uh have a
private contractor run the operation or
whether they want to run it themselves I
believe that most of our uh our
Municipal uh landfills are currently run
by those
subdivisions uh so that's basically what
the bill does and uh a couple of
comments have come up in terms of uh
What uh would this in some way be anti-b
business uh and I don't think so because
uh by requiring a landfill at the state
level to be uh operated by a private
business that is actually creating a
great opportunity and it takes a certain
number of the difficulties off that
business off that management business's
plate they don't need to find the site
they don't need to buy the site they
don't need to they don't need to um be
they don't need to decide whether the
site is appropriate uh th those are
things that the state would take on and
uh the but the private so those things
would would so it would be actually an
advantage to a private business to take
on the running of such a u public
landfill um the other thing is the costs
whether there would whether this would
increase or decrease costs for uh for uh
uh communities who uh have to ship their
uh trash to you know some landfill
somewhere and uh there was some
suggestion that it might increase costs
however one of the things that was
brought up was the transportation issue
and at the moment the current landfills
in the state that are privately run are
located in places that are actually not
that convenient to much of the State uh
the state could decide that uh they
would choose a landfill site that was
more conveniently located to more of the
population and uh therefore reduce the
trans the transportation costs the
fiscal note does mention that that uh
currently the Tipping fees at private
landfills are higher than the current
than the Tipping fees at Municipal
landfills so uh that's also an
indication of where the costs might run
there um so that's about as much as I
have I'd be willing to take some
questions but uh we do have someone who
was on that Solid Waste uh uh out of
state solid out of state and Lim
unlimited um uh service area study
committee who is going to be
testifying uh and I would probably defer
most of the questions to him because uh
he has studied this much more carefully
than I have I do have a question do we
know if any other states do this uh
Maine does this I uh I I know that Maine
does it I'm pretty sure that Vermont
does it uh and I'm I'm fairly sure that
there are others out there uh I don't I
don't have a complete list I think that
might be some something that
representative ger could answer more um
more fully so and also by doing
this would then the legislature be the
one that determines some sort of level
of
percentage of uh how much solid waste
comes in from out of state the
legislature would be uh would be able to
do that uh it is something that we could
either do uh on a legislative basis or
we could do it as part as or we could
put it in as part of the rules making
process but we would it would be um the
the state would have control of that
whether whether it would be the through
the legislative branch or through the
executive branch so would you imagine
that the commissioner of uh Department
of Environmental
Services be the one that determine some
sort of out of state percentage level uh
I don't know exactly how that would work
thank you any other questions
representative Murray thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question I have uh at least one question
around whether or not you see this piece
of legislation potentially being
something that could be considered a
public utility of
sorts I don't think this falls under the
scope of what is considered public
utility because a public public
utilities are generally think things
that are functioning as um as structural
monopolies uh and so that um so for
instance uh
electricity that's a public utility
because it's you can't have multiple
competing uh it it's just structurally
not possible to do that however if
someone knows more about utility law
than I do I would not I I'd be willing
to see that argument so um that's just a
guess I don't know for certain and
followup y followup and then with regard
to I would imagine rfps and bids for
proposals would Dees rules be the person
do you think developing or negotiating
third party management
structure yes it might require further
legislation to um to to to put that into
operation but uh but in term
but Dees would be the appropriate
location
to uh put out an RFP for the management
of a of a
landfill okay representative
Howard if the bill is enacted thank you
madam chairman if the bill is enacted
would it uh preclude um a passage of any
permits that are in the
works I do not know I believe that the
Department of Justice is still figuring
out uh what the status of of current
Curr ly proposed U permits are is
relative to all of this all all the
various bills we're dealing
with representative
com thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question my
question becomes if at some point uh the
existing landfills run out of capacity
and I've heard some interesting
conversation
today um would the state be able to take
by eminent domain for
this uh I I don't know what the
um I I don't know what the I don't know
enough about em eminent domain law in
New Hampshire to give you a definitive
answer my I I have a big recollection of
having passed a bill seever a number of
years ago that severely restricted the
state's capacity to use evident do
domain but I I don't know enough of that
about that portion of law to to say
repres come to our followup yes and
thank you and I understand you don't
know enough about um the eminent domain
law but I do believe that it states that
if it's for the welfare of the entire
State then they can do the taking and I
would be concerned uh that some language
would need to be drafted into something
like this that say land cannot be taken
by emminent
domain if if if there's a um desire to
have an amendment that would uh that
would indicate that I'd be happy to add
that because I'm not crazy about the
idea of an eminent do domain okay
representative
kraton thank you madam chair and thank
you representative Bixby a followup to
that question then is let's say we need
a new land site they the gentleman this
morning said his site was 1500 Acres
we've heard 100 acres so somewhere
between 115 acres 100 and 1500 Acres the
state then has to buy that and so I
don't see that in the financial note
saying okay this is a a lot of land that
the state is
buying so the the question I I I believe
that the question of the actual purchase
of the land would have to be something
that would be subject to further
legislation uh and um
and in terms of the details of how that
would be worked out it would have um and
it may come through as um as a budget
request from Dees if they recognize the
need to purchase land uh it was it's
something that the legislature would
certainly have the capacity to weigh in
on before uh before new land was
purchased it is also possible that are
there are lands owned by the state
currently that would be appropriate for
the purpose and
uh and that is you know that is you know
that's a guess I don't I I I couldn't
say well there's this lot there's this
lot in you know such and such a town
that would work um but uh there may be
appropriate land that's already owned by
the state in which case it would not
require a new
purchase represent H Haskins thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
for taking my um question I I've heard
some different numbers being thrown
around for acreage but is it not true
that Lebanon is 15
Acres I do not know I I I don't I I have
not made a study of the acreage of all
the landfills in the state even though
the number is relatively small uh but uh
I think that uh
the
uh that that's that's a question that is
further down the road in terms of um
whether you know that that would be
something that would fall in into that
further legislation issue as opposed to
uh this bill which is essentially
establishing a baseline policy I believe
that number is accurate however so I
have a question too
about possible conflict of interest I
mean I would imagine the state would
still have to permit this land for use
as a
landfill so if it's a state-owned land
and they're going through with the
permitting process themselves isn't that
a conflict of
interest I I don't think so I think I I
I I can't come up with spe specific
examples right now but I I believe that
there are a number of things that are
regulated by state law that the state
does and issues permits for so that uh
in other words uh I don't think this is
a new problem I think that there uh I I
know that there are uh a number of
existing conflict of interest um uh
statutes or actually there there there
are conflict of interest statutes in
existing law and uh they may already be
applicable uh to this particular
situation uh
any any
Arrangement certain further legislation
will certainly be needed to uh establish
what the how the RFP process would work
and how and that could also include
further legislation in terms of uh how
the permitting would
work okay uh representative nav thank
you madam chair thank you for taking my
question um so it sounds like one of the
main goals of this is to give us more
control on whether we take or how much
out of state waste we take do you see
other benefits to the state owning the
landfill or is that the primary
driving force behind this legislation
the primary driving force is uh that it
gives us control over the out ofate
waste uh a I think a secondary benefit
is that when it comes to actually
sighting another landfill when it's
needed uh it could be sighted in a place
that is more convenient to uh the larger
portion of the population that needs to
be shipping waste than our current
landfill
representative
Katon okay thank you madam chair I'm
just trying to understand what you're
saying so if the state is responsible
for citing it then the state rules that
we're developing don't
apply uh no in fact the state rules the
existing state rules would apply so so
how is that different than I mean I
don't understand why why the criteria
would be you could get a place closer if
a state is doing it versus a private
entity oh well the so um currently there
is a u permit in there's a permit that
has been submitted to the state for uh
developing a landfill and that landfill
is uh in a location that is actually a
fair distance away from a lot of our
population centers and uh one of the
thing one of the driving factors behind
that so
um that location choice is that someone
happened to have that piece of land
available for
sale and uh which is not really the best
way to to decide where you're going to
put a landfill uh
so
um certainly if there is a uh location
that the state happens to own that has
highly porous
soils that's not a place that the
Department should be saying well maybe
we'll put a landfill here so the the all
of the restrictions in terms of what
kinds of soils are necessary what kinds
of setbacks are necessary under current
and the now developing rules would be
applicable to any site that the state
would choose as a as a land landfill
site so uh just because the state owns
it doesn't mean that they can be sloppy
about uh you know what the environmental
uh precautions should be okay thank you
any other questions re uh representative
comto thank you madam chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question I understand the purpose of the
bill however I see a lot of lot more
questions and one of the questions is is
who is responsible for the liability
insurance who is going to responsible if
anything leaks is it going to be the
citizens of New Hampshire is it going to
be the management company I mean there
are a lot of questions here and if the
state already has a suitable place for a
landsite why couldn't they offer that up
for sale to an operator that's willing
to put in a landfill I mean I understand
the underlying intent but I'm just
asking those questions okay so uh the to
the last question uh if the if the site
if the state had a suitable site at the
moment there would be nothing
that there it would not be um out of the
question for the state to offer that for
sale for a landfill to some company uh
but that would require a a different Act
of this legislature because it is uh a
dis disposition of state property and
similarly to the way that we need we
need need to weigh in on things like uh
the state school in lonia
um but
uh okay I forgot the first half of that
question it's okay liability oh
liability that is something that so the
this build does not um purport to be the
uh everything that is needed in order to
to to make this operational this is a
essentially establishing a a baseline
policy and I know that further
legislation will be needed in order to
make this operational and a lot of the
questions in terms of liability in terms
of uh what would be the responsibility
of an operator versus the responsibility
of the state would have to be worked out
in some combination of further
legislation and rules that were directed
by that
legislation representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative could you talk a little
bit about the interstate commerce clause
and how that kicks in okay so I am not
going to say that I'm a constitutional
lawyer I'm not even a
lawyer but my understanding of the con
of the interstate commerce clause and I
I I believe that representative gerana
may be able to speak to this a little
bit more specifically because I think
that there was that that was included in
the report that his uh subcommittee uh
worked on so uh but a rough version of
that is that uh no that states
cannot uh put limits on in on interstate
commerce that will uh in some way
Advantage uh the state over other states
because it's crossing state lines and uh
the way that that comes into play with
the with trash is that the capacity to
uh dispose of trash is considered
Commerce and
therefore uh putting a restriction on of
on waste from out of state that is not
also on waste from in the state is not
something that the state can impose on a
private
business uh however
the state does have the capacity to say
what the state as a governmental body is
willing to accept or not so that and
that's that's basically why I did the
bill this way yes uh so uh
so uh there there may be and we have
another bill coming up that suggests
well maybe we can just put a limit on it
I'm not sure that that's going to work
uh I think that uh in terms of the
Commerce Clause this bill is probably
Sounder uh and uh which is one of the
reasons I I put it forward thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you and I'll
call Representative Nick
gerana thank you thank
you thank you madam chair members of the
committee uh so for the record Nick
uh represent Keen chesher District 1 I
was on the study committee to look at
the
unlimited uh service area permits
landfills for to deal with out estate uh
the question of out ofate uh waste
coming into New Hampshire we met as you
can see uh yesterday representative Ro
Fort handed out the first several pages
of our report I also emailed that report
around I think it was on
Sunday the uh meeting times you can see
we met between the middle of August uh
and the end of August October we
completed our report we had unanimous
agreement it was a bipartisan bamal
committee uh it was myself two
Republican colleagues from the house and
a republican colleague in the Senate who
was the chair of committee the committee
we uh came to a unanimous agreement on
the final report and the one specific
piece of legislation that this
bipartison bamal study group endorsed
was this piece of legislation it offered
a number of other recommendations but
this was the one piece of legislation uh
that we agreed on uh endorsing I'm
confident that uh there may be some
amendments which we wish to discuss and
are open to uh including in the bill I'm
I am reasonably optimistic that that
this is a bill that can make it through
both the house and the Senate into the
governor's desk um I will say I
certainly don't want to make any claims
to knowing things uh that I don't know
or being privy to private conversations
but senator avard who chaired our
committee uh said that he would not
endorse any recommendations that he was
not confident could uh go to the
governor and be signed uh and he fully
endorsed this recommendation uh of the
committee he signed off on the report as
and he uh told the committee and at that
final meeting uh he endorsed the uh and
that was as you said after uh we had had
these disc discussion so uh I am
reasonably confident that we can get
this through both houses and to the
governor's desk the reason why this
particular bill was chosen for the
committee to endorse is really you're
facing three possible solutions to the
to dealing with the issue of outof State
waste number one we could limit some
things certain materials for example
mattresses both for New Hampshire
residents and for out ofate residents
right so there's certain things that we
don't want to landfill because of
concern for uh pasas and other toxins we
could limit them both in state and out
of state that raises questions about
what we would do with our instate
sources of those waste uh that waste
because the interstate commerce clause
says that uh they would have to be
treated equally so that's one
solution another solution which we'll be
discussing this afternoon is the
possibility
of going through the State Commerce
Clause in the sense of in a way
challenging it saying that the
legislature uh mandates a 15%
cap that would have to be litigated
almost certainly we certainly could
Prevail on that I think there's a very
strong argument to be made that we're
talking about resources that belong to
the people of the State of New Hampshire
that landfills affect uh air quality
water
quality uh uh and so for those reasons
it is within our rights to be able to
put a cap on out ofate trash uh but it
is I think a riskier move because we
don't know how that would uh how that
would play out in courts the third
possibility is to have publicly owned
landfills and that could either be
state-owned or owned by a political
subdivision as we do currently have some
like in Lebanon for example uh one that
is owned by a municipality a group of
municipalities could go in together uh
on this uh one of the things that we put
in the bill as an agreement among all of
us on the study committee was that if it
was publicly owned by the state it would
be privately operated the state is not
getting in on this business uh it is not
an attempt to take business away from
operators in the field the purpose of
having it publicly owned is that we can
get around the restrictions on the
interstate commerce clause this is done
in Maine this is done in Rhode Island I
know those are two states in in New
England where they have some uh publicly
owned landfills Vermont has one landfill
it is privately owned but it is subject
to a host of restrictions that we do not
put on our landfills which is why we
have become the place where people send
their trash uh in New
England if we have a publicly owned
landfill not only can we put a cap on
the amount of out ofate trash and I
think we would want to have for reasons
I'm happy to talk about there we would
want
that number to not be zero we would want
that number to be I know 10 15% there
were reasons why we actually do aside
from Strictly economic reasons there are
reasons in terms of how landfills
operate um we would want to be able to
take a certain amount of out ofate waste
but it would give us that flexibility
the other thing that it would do it was
it would allow us to distinguish between
say mattresses or rugs that are produced
as waste within New Hampshire and those
same materials that are problematic to
landfill coming in from out of state
right as in my first example I I said we
would have to treat under the interstate
commerce clause those materials on on
even footing with public ownership we
could say there are certain materials
because we know New Hampshire residents
have to dispose of them that we would
accept in uh these publicly owned
landfills but we could say we're not
going to accept those from out ofate
landfill out of state sources another
benefit of having a publicly owned
landfill is that you can charge
different rates in state and out of
state right now we cannot do that we
have to charge the same rates because
these are private companies um we cannot
require uh outof State haulers to pay a
different tipping fee than instate
haulers having publicly owned land is a
solution to that as well we could under
those circumstances choose to charge a
higher tipping fee for haulers from out
of state which could actually benefit
uh New Hampshire operations and and
perhaps help to help to offset some of
the costs uh for New Hampshire
residents uh Peter uh representative
Bixby pardon me referred to um he he
spoke to concerns that have been
expressed about how this would affect
business is this an anti-business Bill
uh it is not it is uh a bill in facted
in in some important ways benefits these
operations as representative Bixby
pointed out uh the initial outlay of
funds to purchase the property uh would
be State uh a state decision uh and a
state investment uh and also the
question of liability is a good question
and we had a representative from the
Attorney General's office we talked
about this uh yes absolutely the state
would be assuming some liability as the
landholder and quite frankly that's how
it should be because we should be only
citing these landfills in place is that
we have the absolute and utmost
confidence that they're going to be safe
and if it takes saying that the state
has to assume liability for us to make
sure we have the strictest possible
standards and that's what we should do
the other piece of that however is it
does depend on the terms of the lease
right so in the lease you could say if
it is determined that a leak is the
responsibility of the operator because
of operator malfunction liability sh in
certain ways so certainly that that
would be embedded in the lease as
liability issues often are but as said I
don't see having the state assume
liability is a negative thing uh on the
contrary I think uh it it means
hopefully that we will be as serious as
we really should be about where we put
uh these sites so uh I'm happy to answer
other questions about the committee
about our conclusions about the Bill
thank you madam chair okay thank you I
appreciate your um your explanations too
and um my question is is there anything
in law now that disallows the state from
owning a landfill
facility not that I'm aware of do you
know of any reason why they
don't
currently why would we I mean that's my
response to your question is under the
current kind of regime as it were the
way we do landfilling in the state I
don't see any incentive for the state to
do it absent the legislator instructing
uh that to be the
case Okay representative K thank you
madam chair did the committee uh find uh
with state owned land any sites that are
absolutely suitable for this it was not
the charge of the committee to do
that representative
kraton thank you madam chair and thank
you
representative so
I I I don't understand the the the
dollars and cents so today according to
testimony yesterday
47% of the trash comes from out of
state and so if you reduce that down to
10 then you're taking that
37% of uh income from that company away
it's
gone I don't understand how that can be
financially the same I mean if you take
37% of the business that's 37% of the
business where is that how is that made
up thank you for the question uh two
things one is that uh you can charge
more for out of state trash I'm not
going to speculate as to how much of
that margin that would make up for but
that is part of the answer the other
part of the answer as I referred to
before is the the operator would be
spared the outlay of funds in the first
place which is an enormous savings uh on
the on the part of the operator so I
mean I can't give you a a breakdown for
that because we're really working in in
the realm of hypotheticals now because
we're talking about something that may
be cited several years from now we would
need land values we would need all kinds
of information we don't have but th
those are the two pieces that I would
offer an answer to your question number
one they can charge more for out estate
waste that subsidizes the instate rates
uh number one and number two there are
savings for the company by using this
model follow up So the plan then is for
the state the taxpayers of the state to
assume the liability and the cost of
building this that the private company
here to for has assumed so the taxpayers
are now paying for the for buying the
land for site preparation for all the
permits and surveys and and all that
that's all taxpayer dollars now well
it's probably not all taxpayer dollars
but first of all in that cas case that
is I would argue the price that we are
paying to make sure that we don't become
The Dumping Ground of of trash uh from
out of state from here until kingdom
comes so there's a state investment but
I would argue that state investment is
worth it if we can as I said avoid that
fate number one number two
um now I'm blanking at what number two
was but that was the first part of my my
question oh the other is that the the
costs would be potentially shared with
the operator again that would depend
upon how rulle are written and how
contracts are are drawn up I mean
presumably uh The Operators actually
would be would have the expertise would
be in a better position for example to
be able to engage in some of that site
preparation so uh
again we're talking about hypothetical
we're not looking at a a specific
concrete situation in front of us at the
moment but it's not necessarily the case
that the state would assume the entirety
of the cost for preparing a site okay
thank you r representative kulan thank
Madam chair and thank you R ger for
taking my question so if the taxpayers
are going to be funding this are you
open to any kind of amendment to say
that uh it should be the price should be
locked into the lowest market rate at a
landfill for local
people yes thank you very much for the
question that's something I had not
thought about but yes I I think that we
should absolutely all always you know
try to find the lowest rate as we do
when we put out rfps uh in terms of
State contracts so um I hadn't thought
about that as an amendment I'm I'm
certainly open to it and I agree
entirely with the
concept representative Murray thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question I guess with regard to lowest
market rate uh regardless of whether
it's a state contract or Municipal
contract County contract isn't that
normally the norm in which rfps go out
to bid and they look at the contracts
that come back to from those bids to
determine which are the
lowest thank you uh representative that
that's my understanding this is not an
area I know a great deal about but
that's my understanding about how State
purchases are
done represent
Penza just try to put this in a question
I just want
um I just want to understand that that
to clarify on the bill that this is is
really just for the the the plot of land
the suitability of the soil that would
be the only piece that's happening on
the state side of things every
other operation design everything is all
coming in the private realm correct with
this
bill the actual then thank you for the
question uh the actual drawing up of the
contract is not something that that I
can speak to but but we're talking about
the state purchasing the land
determining that the land is suitable
for a landfill and then entering into a
contract with a private operator and my
assumption is that based on the
experience of that operator the state
and the operator would then work
together to prepare the site for when
it's eventually uh opened represent
pretends a
followup so like how it currently stands
the with the private operator that would
be um running the entire operations of
this underneath this realm here they
would have all of that you know in a
sense liability all of everything would
all apply like it currently
does thank you again for the question
that would be determined in the lease
agreement between the state and the
operator as as I understand it based on
our discussion with the Attorney
General's office representative k thank
you madam chair and thank you again uh
rep Jama for taking my
question you had uh suggested earlier
that um the benefit to uh the operator
or the management team of the landfill
is that they would have uh really no
outlay because the state would be
investing in all the capital um but yet
what I just heard and maybe I heard
incorrectly is that the state would only
be purchasing purch ing the land and the
contractor or management company would
then be responsible for all of the um
Capital um that has to go into the
landfill including the liners Etc so I'm
a little bit confused so if you could
clarify from me I'd really appreciate it
yes thank you no that's a an excellent
point uh uh so if we requesting
permission to revise and extend my
remarks uh I would go back and say that
uh there is the initial outlay for the
purchase of the land would be on the
state other costs would I imagine be
determined by the nature of the lease
agreement between the state and the
operator so I I can't speak to that that
outlay and I think representative comp
why you were you were correct that uh
there probably would be other costs
involved so yes you're right followup
yes thank you madam chair so to me um
and land is is expensive
but the preparation of the site to is um
I would say is probably more
expensive than the purchase of the land
uh with everything that you have to do
to prep aite to become a landfill so I
don't see the cost savings to the
businesses really I'm trying to uh
understand
that okay I don't think there was a
question there but
okay well my question then to follow up
on that is what would be the benefit to
the
lesie the waste management company
whatever
to uh install liners and um put in all
the work and money Capital to prepare
the site and run its operations put up
structures
buildings what the benefit of that if
eventually at some point they may leave
that site if another you know say
they're not doing a good job for
whatever reason and the state decides to
then enter into a new contract with
another um Waste Management Company it
seems like you know they're they're
putting in all the capital and work and
they may not be able to um you know they
have no real ownership of it
I think that's a good question I think
the incentive uh is for them to to do a
good job and keep the contract with the
state so that they could continue to
operate the
facility okay representative
Dy thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question okay so I've said
this before nashwa has you know a
municipal landfill um and I I I have to
tell you nobody thinks much about it uh
because it runs pretty well the other
thing is is that in from a municipal
perspective we have a u a commission a
department of a public works commission
uh they're all elected um so you know so
we have accountability uh if things go
wrong with the landfill you know then we
can uh vote out of office those are you
know that are in place so my question to
you um is was any that local control you
know because we've talked we've had a
lot of discussion here about um
citiz residents not feeling like they're
being heard you know in the sighting of
landfill not feeling like they have any
control over it uh did the committee
talk about um the fact that a
state-owned or a municipal owned
landfill uh would give the residents
more local control because they can vote
people in and out of office thank you
for the question that that is not
something we discussed this bill really
wouldn't affect municipalities right
because they currently have the ability
at in as in the case of Nashwood to be
able to operate their own facility so I
think that's an excellent point but it's
not something we discussed in the study
committee representative Murray and then
Penza thank you madam chair um thank you
for taking my question um I did just
want to sort of focus on this this facet
for a minute um the bill does state that
um there are other political
subdivisions that potentially could um
become involved in the running of a
landfill whether it's a regional
Landfill District or a state-owned
landfill district and to that end I
guess I had um a question about whether
or not you envisioned uh to the members
point about elected public works or
elected
entities um do we know how
many municipalities or public
subdivisions elect their Public Works
folks and follow up if I may to that
sure um the second part of that question
then is with regard to some of the
oversight at the state level would would
you envision that those would be
potentially an elected position as
well thank you for the question it's not
something that the committee discussed
the reference to M political
subdivisions here is is here to
distinguish because uh I mean first of
all as you said nothing should change
for municipalities they can currently do
this the reason why they're referenced
in the bill at all is to distinguish
between uh if the landfill is owned by
the state it will be privately operated
and we're not Ming mandate that at the
the municipal level so the only reason
why we reference municipalities in this
case is to make it clear that they can
operate them themselves right that that
when we talk about uh publicly owned
privately operated that that applies
only to state-owned landfills and not to
municipally Owned landfills so no we did
not have a discussion about the
oversight of Municipal
landfills representative Penza and then
representative H
Haskins
I I don't have a lot of information but
I have enough in regards with uh with
Rochester so um the the cost for
land alone that it's not it's millions
of dollars that they've spent do you're
realizing that we're talking about that
just if if we're just talking about land
and and not about the site work and all
of that that would be a private entity
right so it's millions of dollars that
would be a savings for the private
landfill operator correct that is my
understanding okay so then what about
all of the work that's done to make sure
that it is a site that would also be on
the state side as well so that's also
that's drilling of the wells all of that
kind of work that's done for the site
suitable that would also be on the state
correct I believe and thank you for the
question I believe those specifics would
be worked out between the state and the
the operator who has the
lease follow up
follow only because it would be you you
would have to have that for all those
expenses the cost of the land and making
sure it's suitable and all that would
have to be on the state side of things
because then you go to the private
operator to say hey do you want to run
this that's what I'm saying you that's
that's the piece that I think we are
getting getting it's getting muddy isn't
that clear I think that's clear in here
my apologies thank you I I didn't
understand the question yes I mean the
state would have to determine that it
was a suitable site and there is work
involved in doing that and that would be
the state's responsibility before you
can even offer that site to uh a l or in
order to to run the operation so yes
that would also be incurred by the state
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair and thank you
representative are we not talking about
a business business where the profit
margin is not
Slim So if operating if they don't have
to pay the expense for the
land they're ahead of the game and it
would seem to me that we wouldn't have
to worry that they'd want to operate a
landfill because they've just saved a
huge amount of money but yes the money's
on them to build the landfill and to
operate it according to the contract act
with the state is that not correct yes
thank you for the question and as we've
seen in the solid waste management
report we're not reducing nor will we be
over the next 20 years the amount of of
waste that we're landfilling we're going
to be more than 50% behind our Target
goals on the reduction of waste by the
middle of the century so not only is it
currently a profitable industry it will
continue to be so because we are not
even coming close to meeting our
reduction goals uh and and the amount of
material we're continuing to to landfill
uh is not going
down represent dsy yes um Madam chairman
may I make a point of clarification
regarding um the land versus you know uh
improving the land for the um um
contractor in what way what do you mean
well I used to sell RFP software okay so
I understand the process a little bit
and having you know been involved in
County government but my understanding
would would be that the state would
issue an
RFP putting out the scope of what they
want contractors to um give them a price
on okay so you send out the RFP and if
the RFP is unreasonable and businesses
can't make a profit off of it nobody
responds so then what happens is the the
state would go back and revise the RFP
and say okay this didn't work so now
we're going to put out a second RFP and
again if no business responds because
they can't make money the process just
goes on you know so so basically you
know the state might start out with
saying okay we're just going to give you
the land you do everything else nobody
responds second one okay you know we're
going to do the engineering the land the
engineering work d d d d da and somebody
responds and says yeah we can make money
on it so I think that's the way the
process would work um so it really is
kind of an upfront negotiation and a
business will respond when they know
they can make a profit off of it
okay any other questions for
representative
gerana seeing none thank M
chair I would like to call Kristen cotch
from business and industry
Association
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee good
afternoon uh for the record my name is
Kirsten cotch I'm the vice president of
public policy for the business and
industry Association known as Bia we
serve as the state's CH Statewide
Chamber of Commerce um I'll keep my
testimony very brief and just focus on
the business Community perspective of
this issue uh Bia is opposed to House
Bill 1145 we have concerns that this
bill would take away opportunities from
the business Community we're concerned
about the anti-business nature of this
bill it would be a roadblock for future
economic development for the solid waste
industry and ultimately would hinder
growth for the business community in New
Hampshire uh further we're concerned
that one of the underlying purposes of
this bill may be to stop a specific
project from being developed in the
future also I think there are some very
vague portions of this bill it's a short
bill it doesn't go into detail about um
who would be paying for the development
of landfills and how that process would
work and just being able to contract and
and operate landfills doesn't
necessarily alleviate our concerns
because there's still an opportunity
being lost so in conclusion we
respectfully requested the committee
finds this bill inexpedient to legislate
because it would limit opportunities for
future Economic Development and
ultimately weak week in New Hampshire's
business climate thank you I'd be happy
to try to answer any questions thank you
for your testimony do you have written
testimony or did no okay thanks um
so the
um the person who introduced the bill
represent Bixby had mentioned that this
is not what he considers not an anti-
business bill because we would still be
um Contracting
uh waste management companies to run a
business so how does that um comport
with what you're saying is it being
anti-business thank you so I mean your
your thoughts are that a business would
be discriminated against because they
can't own the land that they're
operating on thank you for the question
I I think it's just that the opportunity
is no longer there right they can't own
a new landfill they they could be
contracted to do something we don't know
what that looks like or you know are
they paying to develop it it's it's just
all very unclear but our concern is that
you know now the government is going to
be doing this instead of
business okay representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question I think I um where
I'm stuck is that the profit margin for
this business is huge and so they could
we would in fact need them to most
likely operate a landfill and over many
years of the life of a landfill they
could be expected to make as much as1
billion dollar so I'm really not sure
what the harm to the industry or the
business Community
is could you
elaborate um I think it again goes back
to the fact that there's a lost
opportunity to be the ones in control I
mean they're just operating it's it's
not the same
opportunity represent H Haskins followup
thank you but they would reap the
profits would they not the state is not
getting the profits from the landfill
the industry there's still an
opportunity to gain profit yes thank you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um my question is around the idea and
concept of public private Partnerships
does your does does the Bia have other
uh entities that uh participate in ppps
or public private Partnerships of any
kind thank you for the question I don't
have the answer to that off the top of
my
head representative hkin uh Howard I'm
just
looking just to thank you madam chair um
just to add just to put a finer point on
what um representative of the hkin said
um isn't there in fact a greater
possibility for for profit given that
you do not have to make the investment
in the
land uh thank you for the question I I
don't have the answer to that I don't
think we know
that okay representative Penza you had a
question I just want um I just want to
ask do you understand that the bill
would actually it doesn't change how
anything is operated right now except
for the land the private company would
still reap every bit of all the benefits
so it wouldn't hurt any of their profits
so how could this hurt
business thank you for the question well
I think it was mentioned earlier that
the state would just own the land so if
business had to then develop an entire
landfill and then lost the contract that
introduces an element of
unpredictability which is a real
challenge for the long-term planning for
business followup
followup did you realize that most of
these contracts with with the landfills
are contracts of you know 20 30 year
type
contracts so it's not like it they would
have it and lose it overnight thank you
for the question um I don't think we
have a guarantee of that in this bill
though represent Duty uh thank you madam
chair so if I'm reading the tea leaves
what I'm hearing you say is that um the
only thing that would change would be by
the state being involved in the land um
that there would be State oversight
because the con because there would be a
contract between the state and the waste
management company and if the waste
management company wasn't operating to
the standards the state expected it
could terminate that contract so um what
I'm hearing is that maybe ba Bia is
against State oversight of any business
is that correct thank you for the
question no we're not concerned about
meeting the appropriate standards it's
just a a change in the way things
operate and again a lost opportunity to
do this um have business do this
themselves representive ktoa thank you
madam chair and thank you again for
being here and please bear with me while
I ask this question um I have heard some
information here that because the state
would own the
property and they would be contracting
out the management of the
landfill that the
stakeholders in the land and the
ownership of the property would get to
pay a lower rate versus those that are
out of state but we would be minimizing
the amount of out of state waste that
comes in here would that affect your
profit thank you for the question I
don't have the answer to that
today any other questions from the
committee no seeing none thank you very
much for coming and lending us your
testimony appreciate it I'd like to call
Tom
Tower to come and
speak good
afternoon good afternoon committee
Happy Valentine's Day to everyone for
the record my name is Tom Tower and I am
representing North Country Alliance for
balanced change speaking here in support
of HB
1145 uh I submitted my testimony online
and it's been uploaded so you guys all
have have access to it so I'll speak at
a very high level there's been a lot of
dialogue already around this
topic
everybody in the room has had a lot of
Education whether you want it or not in
regard to solid
waste so let me start my testimony with
a little bit of a story so round about
38 years ago there was a decision in the
state of New
Hampshire to privatize Solid
Waste I suspect that the rationale for
doing it back then was probably a good
idea now you fast forward 38 years and
you go 20 years without an updated Solid
Waste plan and what do we have we've got
a disproportionate amount of out ofate
waste now that's coming in because your
surrounding states are putting the
clamps on new
landfills and New Hampshire seems to be
at the bottom of the funnel so let me
put this in perspective a lot of the
times people say you know
um well New Hampshire exports Solid
Waste as well well that's true but the
last number that that I've seen and
happy to hear anything to the contrary
it's about
5%
um the opposite of that is that we are
importing somewhere between 45 and
50% so the intent of
1145 here is to minimize that call it
inequity in the amount of out ofate
waste in comparison to what we are
exporting
the other piece of this in that is that
if you we would not even be discussing
any of this if out ofate waste wasn't an
issue so the subcommittee that rep
gerana spoke about and um was was uh
membered by you know some senators and
and and representative roacher here
that's going to speak on another bill in
a
moment their task was to look at ways to
minimize the influx of out ofate waste
and one of the proposals that seems to
have Buy in from across the aisle was
that we move to state-owned landfills
there's been a lot of questions around
that it's you can debate it all day long
it's not bad for business this happens
all the time people lease out whether it
be buildings or land they issue an
RFP whoever wants to bid on it that has
done due diligence thinks they can run a
profitable business they basically bid
on it and they come in and there are
contracts like rep Penza said they could
be 10 years 20 years two years 50 years
it depends on the length of the contract
but I don't see this as yanking the rug
out from anybody because after two years
you're going to get tossed after you in
invest millions of dollars on a buildout
are there savings well sure there's
savings because the lands cost millions
of dollars is there money in trash yes
there's money in trash otherwise people
wouldn't be managing in trash there's a
lot of money in it listen to some of the
uh the public companies earnings reports
you'll find out what the margins are
they are
extensive so the intent of this bill is
to minimize out ofate waste and if the
state takes control of that from the
perspective of owning the land then they
can control the influx why because every
time somebody asks the question um well
why is there such a disproportionate
amount of out ofate waste coming in New
Hampshire you know everybody said for
the last 20 years because of the
interstate commerce
clause that's it okay end the story
that's just you know that's that was the
answer this is one mechanism and there's
a lot of people that thought long and
hard about it that it's a good
mechanism it's also not unprecedented in
the state of New Hampshire right you
take a look at Mount Sunapee many years
ago Mount sunap entered into a contract
with with a Colorado based company where
Mount sunap actually is owned by the
state but managed by the Colorado based
company so it's not unprecedented that
this kind of thing happens here in New
Hampshire
so very briefly I'm here to S obviously
urge you to support this bill um out
ofate waste is the elephant in the room
uh we probably wouldn't have talked for
the last two days we still have more to
talk about if we could solve this
problem this is one way to do it are
there complexities yes do I trust that
the committee will work through them yes
this is a good bill I urge you to
support it and I'm happy to take any
questions
sure um I have a question
so you mentioned in what you're were
saying that there's a lot of money in
trash yeah certainly a lot then why
would we want to limit the amount of out
ofate trash why wouldn't we say bring it
to us
let us be the ones to make money on
purifying it recycling it
um doing a lot more other things other
than landfilling it and make money on it
that way and have our entrepreneurs make
money on it that way thank you for the
question Madam chair because right now
it's dangerous you know we we shouldn't
be pulling in all of this stuff that the
the byproduct of which we don't even
know what to do with you you you have
all of this stuff that's that's coming
into New Hampshire it generates you know
for every ton of trash it generates a
ton of lee8 that lee8 is then
transported down to conquered to some
other waste you know water facility and
then it's filtered and runs a lot of it
into the meramac river of which both new
Massachusetts and New Hampshire people
are drinking from and nobody knows what
the heck to do with the posos so I would
think that we would want to minimize the
amount of trash that's coming in because
it's a very dangerous business but I'm
saying if we could use newest
Technologies to figure out ways in which
to um manage that trash coming from out
of state that so it doesn't end up in
landfills then we're still there's lots
of money to be made in that don't you
think um thank you for the question
Madam chair I I would think that there
is money in it and
and what I'm thinking is that if the
state would invest you know more time
into
diversion then you could eliminate a
pretty significant problem and then
there would be money in the management
of it you know creating uh mechanisms to
uh more effectively compost 30% of
everything that goes into a landfill is
food waste if we would have put that
infrastructure in place guess what now
we opened up a entire business
opportunity for anybody that wants to
get into the management of the
composting business and it's the same
with recycling but we need to do it
safely so I would say yes Madam chair
the there is an opportunity um we're not
at that Tipping Point yet but when we
are and that it becomes a profitable
Venture for the for the State of New
Hampshire I would say then you would
maybe open the door for more of it but
this bill would give the state the
ability to control when that door opens
again
okay representative Howard thank you
madam chair um if we were to eliminate
the the income stream from importing
trash would this still be an attractive
business for uh contractors to take over
thank you for the uh question
representative uh Howard that that that
is a good question you know I I can't
speak to at what critical mass at what
Tipping Point does it turn from you know
an unprofitable venture to a profitable
Venture um but I do know that at some
point there will be a need uh I
shouldn't say at some point there will
but there may be a need for for more
landfills um and when that happens you'd
have a contractor bid on it and if they
have done they look at what is out there
for critical mass and they assess
whether or not it's a profitable you
know venture or or or
not represent
dsy thank you madam chair um other than
the law that we have that mercury can't
go into landfills uh what other
recycling bills are you aware of that
this legislature has passed over the
last let's say 20 years uh for Source
reduction thank you for the question
representative Duty uh I have spent so
much time on managing this aspect of
solid waste management I can't speak
intelligently on the amount of bills
that the state of New Hampshire has has
passed but I do know this we can get
that information we'll be happy to
funnel it back to you
representative Penza and then
kulan kind of piggybacking on what um uh
representative Aaron had asked what do
you think about the people of New
Hampshire um in in wanting New Hampshire
to be the mecca of New England
trash I don't know if I should thank you
for that question or not representative
Penza and I'm not sure I know how to
answer that um can you elaborate a
little
further I live in Rochester and we have
a landfill there and um every single
person that I talk to every single one
they have zero idea that we are taking
in that amount of trash they have no
idea the outcry is would be humongous um
that New Hampshire hey come to New
Hampshire We're The Dumping Ground right
so you know if if we're going to use
music Technologies and all of that I'm
all for it but shouldn't we be focused
on New Hampshire instead and then every
other state could be focused on doing
all those things for their
trash yeah thank you for for for the
question um no no question about it you
know these things are very controversial
and Lord knows we've all been talking
about it for a long time many of you
have sat on a number of different
sessions on this
committee um and the one
I believe rallying cry or one of them
anyway is that New Hampshire doesn't
want to be the dump for New England New
Hampshire doesn't want to be the dump
for New England it's that simple why
would we it makes no sense especially
when when the the material that is
coming into the state is a dangerous
commodity it's it's it's very simple so
we've worked real hard to try to get
people to recognize that but I I haven't
bumped into one person unless you have a
vested interest in building a landfill
on the state of New Hampshire when you
say you know what everybody's dumping
all that crap in New Hampshire what do
you think everybody says what I can't
believe that and that's the truth of
this and that's part of what we've been
trying to reinforce representative
kulan thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question uh when I
read this bill I see a need for Consumer
Protections so you talked a little bit
about public private Partnerships Mount
sunap well you know if sunap or gun
stock charged $500 for a lift ticket and
was publicly owned that wouldn't be you
know very good for the public so you
know with waste we pay per ton market
rate so if we were potentially to have
uh publicly owned landfills you think it
would be fair to have the price locked
into the lowest possible market rate or
do you think that you know the rate
should be high or how do you think the
charge on that should go there the
pricing structure yeah no thank you for
that question uh I am not an advocate of
you know the state controlling you know
pricing I I do believe in the free
enterprise system and I think that the
market is going to dictate that pricing
um and that would be my response to your
question any other questions from the
committee thank you appreciate it thank
you members of the committee appreciate
the time and now I call um Sarah us
Kar from New Hampshire
Dees good afternoon Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
I'm Sarah uas Kern and I serve as the
assistant director of the waste
management division at New Hampshire
Dees and with me I have have Leah
McKenna the administrator of the solid
waste management Bureau at Dees thank
you for the opportunity to testify on
House Bill
1145 Dees is not taking a position on
this bill uh but we have some concerns
about how the bill could impact New
Hampshire's Solid Waste Disposal market
and how in turn it could economically
affect New Hampshire communities and
businesses our concerns about potential
disruption of the Solid Waste Market
Center around the observation that
public entities may not opt to obtain
permits to build new
landfills reasons why an entity might
not elect to construct a landfill
include concerns about
liability the lack of a suitable
site inability to obtain financing
inability to obtain local
support and for political subdivision
concerns about the type of expertise
that might be
needed if public entities do not opt to
get permits to construct new
landfills and this bill is enacted this
could lead to a supply pressures on the
solid waste disposal Market which could
drive up the cost for solid waste
disposal my testimony is brief and uh I
would be happy to take any questions
that you
have any questions from the
committee representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question are not some of those issues
in play right now with
um privately run landfills you're right
that those would be a concern for any
entity thank
you okay any other questions from the
committee no seeing none thank you very
much thank you
is there anyone else in the audience who
wishes to comment on this
bill seeing none I'd like to see the
blue sheet and do we have a tally for 33
to 330 people in favor of this bill and
four opposed on the online portal and on
our blue
sheet we have seven in
favor and with that I'm going to end the
hearing for HB
1145 and we are um now going to hear HP
1632 relative to outof State Solid Waste
as we continue talking
trash HB
1632 I believe representative roord good
afternoon we look forward to introducing
this Bill yes thank you madam chair
thank you committee members I I told
some of my com constituents that this is
trash week in conquered and they said
isn't every week trash week in conquered
so yeah I had to I've been waiting all
week for that so I thank you I'm glad to
be back I was here as as you know I was
here yesterday and I'm going to be
talking about referring back to the
report I know representative J Mana has
referred to this as well the report back
um uh that was of SB 159 last year uh
the committee to study unlimited service
area permits for landfills and out ofate
waste coming into New Hampshire and I
know you've heard a lot of the stuff I'm
GNA try to I'm GNA try to make this as
short as I can because I think a lot of
the points that I'm I I'm going to talk
about have been made um the bill
1632 actually let me go back a little
bit here so one of the things I think
that if you if you took a look at what I
sent um yesterday today I sent you about
six pages of 124 pages but the the the
question that has come up when we talk
about out of state trash and just to
Echo what was heard in the previous um
testimony people are appalled at the
amount of out of state trash that's
coming into New Hampshire and you know
as a as a uh somebody from the North
Country who has constituents up there
you were often asked hey what what can
we do about it and for long time we were
operating under the presumption that the
Commerce Clause inhibits our ability to
do anything about that U so we addressed
in the in our committee over the summer
we brought in the Attorney General's
office because we specifically wanted to
take a deep dive into that because we
identified areas where the Commerce
Clause were where we could identify
things that there were differences
different treatments given to people
from out of state versus inst State you
know I'm a I'm a deer hunter uh I buy an
instate deer hunting license and it's
one price but a non-resident deer
hunting license is more expensive an
instate fishing license is one price but
the out ofate fishing license is more
expensive as a pharmacist I'm a
professional instate Pharmacy licenses
Are One Price non-resident Pharmacy
prices are the other price and we asked
the Attorney General so why you know if
there's the Commerce Clause that says
everybody has to be treated equal why is
there this disparity and um he said well
actually there's a way there are
criteria if met that it's not a blanket
you can't do this and uh that's spelled
out in the the the handout that I gave
out uh yesterday and they identified
three criteria it's called The Balancing
of benefits and if three criteria can be
met by the state then the
benefits are balanced the the benefits
are more beneficial to the state than
they are to an out of state person for
instance you know the the state of New
Hampshire um we have fishing game
officers that we pay out of the general
fund uh or part of our budget um that
are funded uh and and and that's why we
can charge more for hunting licenses you
know they use our roads they use our
equipment they so there's a balancing of
benefits if you will so when we pose the
question
to um Mr whims hat he he came up and uh
testified at our meeting and we asked
the the we asked about the balancing of
benefits benefits and we posed the
question can these three be met very off
the top of his head said absolutely two
two out of the three can ve be very
easily met we could prove that case very
easily to limit out of state trash um
and he said the third he said you know
that would be a question of uh um you
know to further explore but he wasn't
you wasn't to know answer out of that so
that being said we went then went back
and took that information said well if
we can do this if there's if there's
basis for doing this and if it's not a
constitutional issue anymore um then
then we should pursue this so what 1632
does is it says any new landfills we
we're not going to again being you know
uh sympathetic to to the businesses that
are conducting business in the state you
we don't want to um pull the rug out
from under them we want to let them
continue on their business model but any
new landfills permitted uh this bill
just says that they cannot accept any
more than 15% of waste from out of state
and where does the 15% come from well I
got to be very honest with you this was
Bill that we there was some
miscommunication amongst the committee
members uh who was going to file this
and with seven minutes left before the
filing deadline I put the bill in um
with the permission of the speaker uh
lot lot was uh uh we we we asked
permission to do this so I picked the
15% um quite frankly out of the air but
uh thinking that the uh the the
committee would have the time to to work
that out but I have had time to research
this and so looking back at how much how
much trash are we taking from out of
state um in 2014 the best management
practices of the New Hampshire Solid
Waste facilities uh which was prepared
by the solid waste compliance Assurance
section um
said we approximately import 5% excuse
me we
we I'm I may be misspoke export versus
import we import obviously as we know
about 50% but how much are we exporting
because the question is when we come up
with this 15% it should be fair to what
we're doing if we're importing uh excuse
me if we're we're exporting 50 % it
would be unfair of us to make the
Imports any more restrictive than that
so when when we found out where that
understanding where that 15% and see if
that's a valid number looking at this
report from 2014 I know the previous
testimony said this U this report said
approximately 5% of our trash is
exported this was in
2014 and that
5% U going back to 1980 was largely un
change there was ups and downs and there
were a little bit of changes depending
on the year so that was a for 2014 that
was um fairly old so I found in the
biannual Solid Waste report in October
of 2019 this is the most recent number
that I could put my hands on this was by
Environmental Services it said Dees
attempted to account for all Solid Waste
generated within New Hampshire destined
for disposal by including the amount of
solid waste generated in New Hampshire
that is exported to Solid Waste
facilities um the average export rate
for solid waste during this they went
back 17 years was 10% and the standard
deviation was about
14% so the number that I came up with in
1632 limiting Imports to 15% is an
equitable number that's that's relative
to how much that we're we're exporting
um it's not lost on me the fact that we
don't take care of everything in State
uh and and we wanted to be you know
sympathetic to that so that's um that's
where that number came from I know I've
had a lot of people ask me about that so
going forward we feel comfortable that
this this bill if enacted would meet the
three criteria that have to be met the
balancing of benefits in the Commerce
Clause we feel that the 15% limit on
non-resident trash coming into New
Hampshire any newly permitted facilities
would be adequate um and uh and and we
feel that this would deliver the
solution that our constituents are
wanting I think that representative
Penza who's left you know her the the
what her constituents say is the same
thing that M mine do we can't believe
how much trash we we put in our our our
facilities I would ask I know I've
spoken to representative J about this to
tune up a little bit the definition of
out ofate I think that he's prepared to
offer an amendment at that time um and
we can do that but I would take any
questions that the the committee might
have at this point representative
kraton thank you for your testimony and
your hard work on trying to make this
work I'm just trying to
square you said that there's no impact
from a business perspective even though
you're taking
away the 35% if you use your number 50
down to 15 so
that's money coming in to the waste
facilities from out of state that's
representing 35% of their
overall prod and and I think how is that
not an impact well and I think that this
that
correlates you're absolutely right in
that point but going back to what the
committee one of the recommendations of
the committee was in conjunction with
this the state really focus on I think
the chair hit on this a few minutes ago
is uh making our abilities and our our
facilities uh for advanced Recycling
incineration and and really focusing on
on making those more robust and working
with opportunities there so where you
may be losing opportunity in one one
bucket the goal would be to increase
opportunity in the other and the other
thing to speak to on that is really this
you know we we think about um if this is
met this was actually this would
actually we we figure would actually
extend the life of some of our
facilities that we have now so where a
facility may only be able to operate
over a certain given a time it's full
and then it's over by limiting this you
actually extend the life and opportunity
to to to to to earn for a longer period
of time follow follow up but it fair
enough
but is there anything that says that
they can be profitable losing in with
your numbers 35% of their
input you the committee didn't explore
profitability of businesses um you know
the committee was tasked with how do we
control out ofate waste so you know
profitability was not addressed in in
the committee okay and and so just to
clarify again because of
the concept of balancing of
benefits limiting it to 15% or some
number is not going to um be on constit
considered
unconstitutional as long as the three
and and I I I I I gave you the um the
brief from the attorney Assistant
Attorney General's office and what was
given to us that balancing of benefits
there are three criteria I believe is a
pike case uh that have to be met if
those three criteria are met then there
that alleviates it's the Constitutional
uh concern Attorney General's office
sent you a memo regarding that yeah
actually I G I don't know if you have
what I gave you yesterday um on that
it's uh it was from uh it's dated
December 14 2021 from K Allen Brooks he
actually came and testified uh to the to
the committee if you don't have that
I'll leave this with you I would like to
another I can I can leave that withk
other questions represent Bixby yes so
um and one of the other
another aspect of looking at that
35 or 35 remaining percent of uh out of
state waste that might be excluded uh
are there not uh impacts of that waste
on New Hampshire where New Hampshire
resources are being used to deal with
that out ofate waste things like you
know the what happens when that goes
into Municipal the when the lee8 goes
into Municipal uh
uh water treatment plants and then get
spread on our Fields what happens when
uh there are potent what happens when
there need to be regulatory actions by
Dees that our taxpayer money is paying
for so that that I think goes back to
that balancing of benefits right I mean
that that that all of that waste that's
coming in by cutting that out out or or
reducing that that's to the benefit of
New Hampshire in many and you can make
that case in many you know our roads
aren't getting used as much you know
there's a you know the the the the
potential for wa water quality or water
issues decreases you know the stuff
that's coming in a lot of it is the
worst stuff you know that that they
don't they don't there's a reason they
don't want it in Massachusetts and and
Connecticut because it's bulky it's
construction waste it's it's it's uh
it's stuff that you know it's not you
know it consumes a lot of space in their
their landfill so I think going back to
that that that that's an argument right
there that you just mentioned is the
balancing of benefits I mean there is
benefit to keeping that out there's
benefit to New Hampshire and New
Hampshire residents and New Hampshire
taxpayers to keeping that out of New
Hampshire representative Murray thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question would it be fair to say that
probably since around the 1980s that
some of our neighboring states have used
that balance of benefit kind of
conversation to enact other things like
disposal by permit for certain types of
things or uh dumping search charges uh
for disposal of certain types of things
that have uh in in somewhat kind
of created the burden that we are now
facing yeah I think that's fair to say
yes and I think they they have been
creative and you look at what some of
our bordering states have done whether
it's you know the ownership structures
or organizational structures that
they've employed um they certainly are
using that to balance the
benefit uh uh of their trash situation
yeah representative ger and then dosy
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
it it was the unanimous bipartisan
conclusion of the committee that we
should make efforts to reduce out of
state trash correct yeah unequivocally
yes and and did did if may I follow up
follow up thank you uh and did the
committee hear from a single person who
told us that it was not imperative to
reduce outof State waste coming into New
Hampshire no I don't believe anybody
anybody came and said it's not a not not
an issue thank you yeah represent dsy
thank you madam chair so um these are
multi-million dollar multi-billion
dollar corporations so is it fair to say
that that if they and trash is trash
it's there so if they pick up trash and
they can't export it to New Hampshire
that it wouldn't cost them probably
anything because they're going to find
another place to export it to would that
be a fair statement you know I don't
want to comment on the profit margins
and affordability of them to do that but
but what was what came out of the
committee is there are places that will
take that gladly um um you know there
are states there are you know in their
ways to get that trash there so yeah
there's there there are places for it
that are not New Hampshire followup just
one followup yeah and in with your uh
the export numbers uh did those numbers
include the recyclables that go down to
the murf that cassella takes down to the
murf in Bill R is that considered part
of our export number or not that I don't
know I don't know if that is or
not representative kulon and then Bixby
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my question uh representative one
thing I'm curious about in this
committee did you ever hear from the
state of Massachusetts or where are they
on this issue of trying to cut down on
Source
reduction um thank you for the question
uh we did not hear from the state of
Massachusetts um and and with all due
respect I serve the people of New
Hampshire not the Massachusetts so quite
frankly I don't care what Massachusetts
thinks about about uh what we do here
under this
Dome follow follow up I mean do you
think we hear about the amount of trash
coming from Massachusetts all the time
do you think it would be a acceptable
Act of diplomacy to not talk to anyone I
mean it's not that far from
us I mean I I
I
again I I I I I have a hard time
empathizing with the with the state of
Massachusetts um you know they don't ask
us uh about their taxes or their laws
that they pass um you know I can freely
carry a gun here in New Hampshire and I
can't in Massachusetts they didn't ask
our permission whether that was
appropriate or not uh and I could get
into other situations of that so quite
frankly I again I don't I don't really
care what Massachusetts thinks about
what how we run our government up here
thank you representative Bixby so um
just uh to get for a little bit of
clarity uh this bill is about capping uh
waste outof State waste that goes into
landfills correct correct yes so so if
we had uh an industry here that uh
developed to do Advanced recycling or to
do other processing of uh of recyclable
plastics or processing of recyclable
paper or you know uh any sort of uh
value added processing of waste then
that would not count as to towards that
15% that that's correct and going back
to the report of the committee the
committee was enthusiastic you know
about exploring opportunities of of
recycling and expanding our abilities to
recycle uh amongst other things so so
this is this would not be uh this would
not not include the recycling again the
the the the purview of the committee was
to be um you know expanding our
recycling abilities here in New
Hampshire thank you pres NAB thank you
madam chair um you mentioned earlier
clarifying something in the Bill about
the definition of out of state could you
speak to that yeah and I think I don't
have the amendment with me but if you if
you look at the um uh line
four
um uh it's a short bill right line four
it says paragraph shall not accept more
than 15% of solid waste transported from
out of state I think we're going to put
something in there to the to to to to be
uh essentially say generated from out of
state you know so we don't want to make
a loophole and uh and the idea was to
you know we felt that it could be
interpreted as a loophole and to uh to
tighten that up a little bit Yeah
representative Murray thank you thank
Madam Shar and thanks uh for taking my
question this is sort of a followup on
representative nab's question it did
occur to me
um with the concept of of of waste
generated out of
state would in Internet Commerce or any
type of thing that is sort of arriving
not via sort of a New Hampshire entity
play a part in this conversation in any
way uh that was not
considered in the committee but um if I
may if you got a package from Amazon you
wouldn't consider that waste until you
took the item out of it right so I think
that probably you if that that's my own
interpretation of that uh it's not waste
until the value is out of it if you will
or the product that it's carrying so I I
wouldn't consider that out of state
waste you know a box that comes in that
you know from the internet traffic and
again that's my own opinion uh it wasn't
addressed in the committee
um but that would you know I you know
the the that wasn't what the target was
if you
will any other questions from the
committee um I I do have a question
so if we could limit the amount to say
15% of so um Solid Waste could we also
limit it to certain types of waste you
know maybe not take demolition maybe not
take mattresses maybe not certain things
or is that does that tread on the
Constitutional Commerce Clause yeah as I
understand it balance of benefits yeah I
mean that's as I understand I'll give
this to you so you can read it as well
um yeah but as I understand it if the if
the burden of the balance of benefits
can be and I'm not an attorney um you
know if the burden of the balance of
benefits can be shown then I think that
the limitations can be can be imposed um
I think that's the challenge that's the
you know that's the bar is proving the
balance of
benefits okay thank you representative
Duty thank you uh one last question do
you see this as an either or between um
HB 1145 or your bill or would you prefer
to see both of them passed you know
that's a good question somebody actually
just posed that to me you know the other
day if we have this do we need this and
um you know I think that the end result
is to limit I mean to limit out of state
trash I mean you've heard it for the
last two days New Hampshire has becoming
uh if not is The Dumping Ground of New
England and I think that's shocking and
it's startling and uh the goal is to
stop that you know I mean it it's the
end of the day it's and it's not so much
the trash it's what happens down the
road with the trash you know the water
the contaminants or whatever um so at
the end of the day the the the the goal
is to limit that that burden that
external burden that we're we're seeing
so I
mean you know the committee came out
with a number of
options um you know the the committee's
report wasn't either or it was these are
the things that we feel based on our you
know our our conditions could help this
so I think going back to the report
these were the findings of the committee
it didn't say you have to do them all
but we felt that any one of these would
help in uh in in alleviating some of
that okay some of that burden
representative K thank you madam shair
and thank you representative for taking
my
question um in reading this bill any new
landfill would be limited to 15% of out
ofate waste in the previous Bill we were
told we would be taking out of state
waste but there was no limit I mean we
could determine a limit but but there
was no limit set so would you
say determining between the two if it
really is the goal of limiting out ofate
waste that putting a number of 15% would
actually do that I think a 15% would
would do that I mean for any I mean I
think that
it yeah I think the net effect would be
similar this is going to cap you a solid
number a
15% uh whereas the previous bill it
would leave that further down the road
for for of that discussion and that
number May evolve I mean the state is
tasked with reducing waste completely um
and and that that number may be may be
uh may be moving um you know the 15%
really when you look at how much looking
at the fairness of of you know with our
what we're exporting versus what we're
importing I think the 15% represents a
fair a fair number um and I you know I
feel confident about that like I said I
started off thinking you know I need to
get something to get this bill in but as
I did the research I think we can
validate that number right now followup
and yeah thank you and your explanation
was perfect um so thank you for that uh
it was very understandable my other
question is and I'm not sure if it was
part of the purview of your committee
but hazardous waste in itself um not
sure if that is part of the numbers that
you looked at because it is my
understanding that New Hampshire exports
all of its hazardous waste um and do you
know what percentage of waste in general
that that
represents yeah I think the the the the
the committee did recognize the fact
that we do export waste there are some
things that we export um the um all that
I can tell you is the numbers that I
that I I would assume that that hazard
waste exported was included in the
numbers you know the 5% 10% you know the
14% with one standard deviation I
believe that that was probably in I
would have to but I don't know for sure
um so you know if it's not then we we
could accommodate for that uh with an
amendment but um um I just looking at
the comprehensive I think Dees does a
pretty good job with these reports and
uh um unless unless they want to talk to
that I I would have to assume again I
know that's dangerous sometimes but I
have to assume that that's
included represent ger thank you madam
chair I was just thinking with as you
were reiterating the point about the
balance of benefits which is key to uh
you know having this past constitutional
muster the fact that we uh base our
capacity projections only on instate
production of waste right so that's not
taking into account the waste that we're
bringing into out of States isn't that
also another another piece of this
argument about the balance of benefits
because their capacity is actually
pegged to instate waste production yeah
I think that yeah I mean that's uh you
know when when you and gr I understand
that the the goal of the state is to
reduce the amount of stuff in the um um
you know that we're putting in the
ground but I think you're right I would
agree with you uh on that thank you any
other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much represent roord
I call Wayne Morrison to come and speak
on this
Bill thank you very much if you want
that to yeah I would like an
email
did you get a copy of this yeah we got
that yes
okay I got a couple of copies now
yeah good afternoon good afternoon
Madame chair thank you for the
opportunity to uh provide testimony um I
would start by first I would like very
much to thank U representative rokford
representative ger and representative
for taking on some very complicated um
and and difficult to navigate uh
conversations and to kind of delving
into this problem it's uh it's overdue
it's greatly needed and it's greatly
appreciated um in the interest of time
I'm not going to read through my my um
testimony um and I I know you've heard
quite a bit from me in the last couple
of days and I promise this is the last
time you'll have to hear from me today
um I did want to I did want to highlight
a couple of points um I think what we're
talking about in terms of autate waste
and I'll use rough numbers but they've
been pretty consistent we're talking
about a million tons of trash that comes
into New Hampshire pretty much every
year which is an enormous amount it's
it's uh it's it fluctuates from year to
year but that's kind of the rate that
we're
at and to the question of profitability
and you know
uh companies choose to be in the
businesses they're in I wish them all
good luck um it's a complicated business
we we want we want companies to prosper
and we don't uh in any way wish to
restrict their their making money at the
business but the state of New Hampshire
and the people of New Hampshire don't
participate in that profit
poll the out ofate companies that that
send us their
trash charge tipping fees they have
transportation fees
um and they Prof profit profit greatly
from this
business that model also it results in
very large landfills being developed in
the state and to the point about
reducing the amount of trash that they
would
process at the front end of that process
what that would yield is landfills that
are tailored for the amount for the
volumes of trash that are generated in
the state of New Hampshire
with 15% or whatever else we would
assume would be the number that we would
allow um for out ofate waste in my mind
that's a much better model than building
an enormous
landfill tailored for pulling in trash
from all over New
England so I think
a state private company partnership is a
very good model to think about we would
have much stronger stronger voice in in
the size of those
landfills the other part of that is the
carbon footprint of the current model if
you think about trash coming into New
Hampshire most of our landfills of size
the private
ones are in the northern part of the
state trash has hauled hundreds of miles
up 93 I don't know if you notice the BMI
trucks going up
they're coming from from Boston they're
coming from far and and it wouldn't
surprise me if if we would start seeing
trucks from places like Conneticut
because they've also changed their their
laws and they're getting out of the
landfill
business trucks go all hundreds of miles
they dump the trash turns into lee8 we
tank our trucks go 100 miles back to
conquered the lee8 gets processed
through the waste facilities and into
the meramac river it is not not in any
way an efficient model in terms of the
carbon footprint and the environmental
impact of all of
that the model that we have today and
the reason that we need either to go to
a u municipally owned landfill or to
restrict uh to
15% is that there is no absolutely no
incentive for the private companies to
change this model in fact it's it's
they're incentivized to bring more and
more and more in a ton of waste is a ton
of waste is a ton of waste wherever it
comes from and the Tipping
fees it doesn't matter to them it it's
all profit it does matter to the people
of New Hampshire so I I think either one
of these models or both of these models
are imperative for us to get control of
the waste that comes into the
state
um profitability and and the investment
that we want I think um we want to
reinforce a model that moves away from
landfilling and I think the legislature
over time should be moving
towards freezing our
landfall uh footprint and working on
diversion where is the investment in
composting and Recycling and diversion
activities there are creative new
business opportunities in those areas
that will help the state of New
Hampshire um I think the fact that the
committee includes Senator avard which
not to be flippant but I I assume uh
there was some interesting conversations
it's terrific that Senator avart is on
board with this um I think uh we have
fought diligently over the years to try
and address this issue and this is the
most progress we've seen in terms of
actually rolling up our sleeves and
trying to do something this model
already exists in other states it works
Works um and now is the time to do it so
I I would encourage us to to complete
the work make amendments if we need to
but a lot of the heavy lifting has been
done this is this is the direction the
state needs to go and the model is both
beneficial to the state and it also will
be beneficial to the private companies
they will still have a thriving business
model I think our our objective as a as
a as C C and the legislators is we want
to shift that model we want more
investment in other areas we want to
slow down landfilling and we want to
increase diversion activities and this
is a good start to doing that thank you
when I take any questions thank you any
questions from the
committee no thank you very much for
your testimony this
afternoon I'd like to invite Haley Jones
to come and speak and you've asked for
three
minutes
hi everybody you already know me um for
the record my name is Haley Jones and
I'm the Vermont and New Hampshire state
director with slingshot where we work
alongside communities most impacted by
environmental threats to takeing at
polluters and build community power and
I'm here to testify in support of House
Bill 1632 uh which would prohibit newly
permitted Solid Waste facilities from
accepting more than 15% of solid waste
from out of
state it's no secret if you've been
reading the news that New Hampshire has
become a Dumping Ground for out ofate
waste and as we've fallen behind in
regulating our waste stream
Massachusetts and other states have
started sending more trash and
importantly construction and demolition
debris to towards our less regulated
commercial
landfills in fact almost half of our
trash is trucked in from other states
with 900,000 tons dumped in commercial
landfills in 2020
alone so this influx of out ofate waste
is bad in terms of landfill capacity yes
um and many people have and will speak
to this in their testimony but I'm
actually here to speak about the
environmental health impacts of this
disproportionate waste flow when we see
thousands of tons of additional waste
pouring into New Hampshire from
surrounding states we're seeing
increased risk for water and air and
noise pollution we're seeing increased
risk for wear on te whoa wear and tear
on our already vulnerable
infrastructure and we're seeing heavier
burdens on communities who are already
living with the impacts of incinerators
of super fund sites and of let's be real
mismanaged
landfilling
we've seen time and time again
especially in the cases of Bethlehem and
Rochester that our existing landfills
are providing little to no public
benefit and pretty much anybody living
near those landfills will tell you that
yet for some reason big corporate waste
hollers and their allies are continuing
to push for expanded capacity and
they're saying you know we've got so
much waste coming into landfills we we
have to we have to build more that's not
getting at the root cause of our waste
problem and it's a little too convenient
in my opinion that in this pursuit of
ever expanding profit margins big
wasters are forgetting that half of our
trash is coming in from other states so
let's not sacrifice the health and
well-being of our residents to line the
pocketbooks of the waste industry and
rather than allowing ourselves to
continue being The Dumping Ground of New
England let's take control over our own
Futures by limiting out ofate waste
giving our Reg Regulatory Agencies and
our small towns time to think about true
zero way Solutions like extended
producer responsibility like reuse and
repair systems and strengthen composting
infrastructure and let's be clear I'm
not talking about chemical recycling
here I'm talking about zero Waste
Solutions um so I'll just end by saying
that as a young person who's going to
live with the consequences of today's
decisions I hope that you will all vote
a to pass on 1632 and make it the
strongest that it can be thank you so
much for your time and I'm happy to take
questions any questions no thank you
appreciate your testimony this afternoon
and I have Sarah
yasar from D New Hampshire
Dees good afternoon Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Sarah uas Kern
assistant director of the waste
management division at Dees and I still
have with me Leah McKenna the
administrator of the solid waste
management
Bureau at Dees thank you for the
opportunity to testify on House Bill
1632 Dees is not taking a position on
this bill but has concerns that we'd
like to relay about how um the
requirement that it would put in place
may be subject to Legal challenges
additionally we have some uncertainty
about the potential impact of the bill
on the amount that New Hampshire
communities and businesses would pay for
solid waste
disposal we understand that while
existing facilities would not be subject
to the limitation in this bill newly
permitted Solid Waste facilities would
be limited to accepting no more than 15%
solid waste from out of
state uh the Commerce Clause of the US
Constitution which has been mentioned
already this afternoon is commonly
interpreted to to prevent a state from
prohibiting or restricting commercial
Solid Waste facilities from accepting
and disposing of out ofate
waste if enacted we're concerned that
the provisions of this bill would
subject de would sub excuse
me if enacted we're concerned that
the provisions of this bill would
subject Dees decisions on permits which
would incorporate the requirement in the
bill to Legal challenges based on the
Commerce
Clause regarding the impact on Solid
Waste Disposal costs we're not sure what
those would be it would be possible that
disposal costs would decrease because
more landfill capacity would be
available for local Solid
Waste it's also possible that by
limiting the universe of a of waste that
a facility could receive the facility's
ability to operate at fully permitted
capacity would be limited so the
operation cost costs would increase
which would also increase waste disposal
costs I also wanted to clarify um some
information earlier when representative
Bixby questioned whether the bill only
caps the amount of outof State Solid
Waste going to landfills or whether it
would uh include solid waste going to
recycling and other types of facilities
when I read the bill line three says any
solid waste facility Solid Waste
facility includes waste to energy
facility transfer station recycling
facility so any of those types of
facilities that receive a permit um on
or after the effective date would have
the cap applied to the waste that they
accept those are the concerns that we
hoped to bring before you and I would be
happy to take any questions that you
have questions from the
committee representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair thank you for taking my
question do you know when this um
particular paper was drafted by the
commissioner from here I can't see what
you have I'm assuming the one that you
just passed out the one dated February
14th was written yesterday and signed
today by the commissioner and it was
reviewed by our director Mike wisat and
approved by him okay follow up if I may
follow and I assume they have read the
report of the solid waste working
group it was the committee it was the
study committee study committee that I
don't know I have not seen a copy of it
myself I'm sure we could make one
available thank
you yes because in the in this
report in this report they do um mention
um The Memo from Department of Justice
regarding the Commerce Clause thank you
we'll look forward to reading it
sure represent M
Duty uh thank you madam chair I must
admit I'm a little confused because we
just heard
testimony that uh it was director whimet
who met with the committee and pointed
out that there were definitely ways to
meet the requirements of the Commerce
Clause two particularly right off the
bat and one that they might have to
massage a little bit so I'm confused
that um director whimet would directly
you know contradict that in this letter
um and I'm a little confused why we've
seen you know a lot of letters signed by
commissioner Scott but in the five years
that I've been here I couldn't tell you
what commissioner Scott looks like so is
there any reason why the letter writer
uh has not chosen has chosen not not to
come and um defend his comments to the
committee de's letters are written by
the agency as a whole and all of our
letters of testimony are signed by the
commissioner I too was perplexed by the
testimony earlier uh given that Mike
whimet had significant input into this
letter okay any other questions from the
committee seeing none
um thank you for your testimony
appreciate
it okay uh is there anyone else in the
audience there who would like to speak
on behalf or in opposition of
1632 with that I have the blue
sheet online we have 311 people in
support
report and zero in
opposition and then on the blue sheet
here we have six persons signed in favor
of this bill and with that I'm going to
end the hearing on HP
and I just wanted to to let the
committee know we had scheduled for
today work session that begins at
3:30 and we have um finished our
hearings um
early so uh I had uh sent a um a message
to the clerk of the house uh regarding
asking him if we could start our work
session earlier and unfortunately we
cannot because when you notice something
you can not start earlier than what we
um notice
so we'll have to stay those who wish to
stay on uh to um engage in the full
committee work session you're welcome to
if you have some other pressing issues
and need to leave uh I would understand
but uh I'm going to uh end our hearings
for this
afternoon and um we we can reconvene at
3:30 representative Howard thank you
madam chair um do we have a list of
bills that will be work on yes the bills
that we uh were going to discuss were
the bills that we heard
yesterday um let me just verify
that yep and let's
see yes we heard the bills um HB 1687 HB
1132 HB 1170 and hb1 1620 were the bills
that we heard yesterday so we were going
to discuss them this
afternoon sure representative Duty can I
just make a comment about a term that we
continue to use and that is the term
Advanced recycling it really is Advanced
incineration there's nothing to
recycling means you know I mean
basically that you take a can an
aluminum can and you recycle it and you
get another aluminum can um this is
really waste to energy so I
mean it is not Advanced recycling Peter
tell me if if there's what's recycled
what do
you so uh as as we defined in our in the
bill we passed last term uh Advanced
recycling main the chemical products
from Advanced recycling may not be used
for fuel thank you you can keep this and
uh what happens with the products of
advanced re of the chemical recycling is
which is probably a better term for it
is that they are are uh essentially
you're you're getting something that is
similar to oil from the chem from the
chemical recycling process those uh
chemicals are used to make new Plastics
and uh can also be used to make waxes
and other
lubricants uh so uh the so it is in fact
recycling there is a uh there is it's
not 100% because there is loss there is
loss in mechanical recycling as well
even for things that are fairly
efficient like paper uh
so uh I think the loss rates may be
higher with chemical recycling but uh
the current rate of of uh of recycling
is I believe somewhere in the 80 to 90%
range for chemical
recycling so it is in fact recycling it
is it is not without its problems but it
is not
incineration okay so um let's take a
break till
3:30
all right dear committee
members we are back and we are gonna
discuss four bills this
afternoon just want to get an idea where
everybody's what everybody's thinking on
these
um we have
HB
1687 relative to disposal of
construction and demolition debris from
State construction
projects and um I know we had testimony
on this and I believe uh representative
Murray is working on an amendment for
this bill would you like to explain what
you're working on thank you madam chair
yes um so in testimony we heard
yesterday about the fact that this is
really limited to State contracts and
that's really all that it is looking to
clarify language around contracts that
the state holds uh and in that I really
the main and primary um concern that uh
folks had was making sure that
um waste hazardous waste and hazardous
materials were equally defined as their
own separate definitions because they
are in fact different so that is really
what we're looking to clarify and that's
the extent of I think what was necessary
um but I'm open to hearing other
thoughts so um line seven of the
proposed
bill um where it says all hazardous
material so you are intending on putting
all hazardous material as defined by RSA
B2 be U Roman numeral 7 I think and
hazardous
waste as defined by RSA 147 B2 Roman
numeral 8 and so that that makes that
definition there that's correct okay
repres and then oh sorry go ahead and
then I think we were discussing about
whether or not it applied to University
Systems and it was in testimony that it
did yeah because it is included in the
statute um in in the entire statute
there representative NAB and
then we'll go over there thank you I
just oh God sorry um do you need my
microphone yeah no you're fine um I just
uh the representative from Dees
yesterday made a comment about how
Asbestos and pcbs were separately
governed and so I just wanted to make
sure that they were covered in the
statutes around hazardous materials and
hazardous waste and didn't need to be
separately called
out could you just so should could that
just be clarified when you do the
amendment make sure they're includ they
are already included as far as my notes
say that they
um Mr piset from
Dees mentioned that we already do this
it's already required to be
done Madam chair yeah it was my
understanding that they have their own
separate categories and how they they're
managed and if I heard that incorrectly
then I think there are two folks from
the department but um unless I've heard
otherwise
incorrectly
yeah sure represent Contour thank you um
from a construction standpoint even in
the private sector you must separate out
asbest um because it is clearly defined
and how it is disposed of that's right
okay and and the fact
is they're saying that these separations
for these State projects for all intents
intents and purposes are already done
but
that by specifying this with this bill
it would improve compliance
and um that's kind of what I got from it
too thank you madam chair I think that
yes that's what I had inferred that they
were um just eager to tighten that up
and just for clarity sake that yes that
it was already done but just okay
representative Howard um quick question
did did we um determine that uh road
construction was included in this Bill
yes yes I think they
said okay you let me let me just take a
peek at
RSA
whoops
yeah I'm looking at
RSA 149
M go right ahead uh so um one of the
things that I I think that's important
to note is that they they said that uh
all of the that this the separation for
State projects is and and for private
Pro projects is already required in
rules but there's no particular
oversight of that and that having it
listed in the contract would uh help um
strengthen compliance
right
okay so considering um the
clarifications that representative
Murray is bringing in an
amendment it would seem to me that the
committee would be okay with doing an
otpa on this bill at some point yeah
yeah I'm good yeah I'm good
okay uh discussion anybody else have any
discussion about hb6
1687 okay HB 1132 relative to permits
for the sighting of new
landfills so let me
go to my
tab and this had to do with the
brownfields and um anybody have any
comments about that particular Bill
representative kulon uh yeah I want to
say that I I like this
and um I think it could benefit
from uh maybe like an interim study to
kind of broaden it to alleviate some of
the problems with Dees I think it's
smart to consider these Brown field
sites for different Waste Management
solar or Advanced recycling uh
facility representative Duty did you
just kick
him
uh I had sent out an email to the
committee also uh with some information
that the es has on their website
regarding Brown fields and then they
have a database that's searchable of all
the brown fields in New Hampshire there
are over 300 of them
um yeah so I just wanted to let you know
that represent Bixby and then kraton and
then ktoa yeah I I think that um there
may be potential uses for
brownfields that uh would be um
appropriate but I don't think that uh
that landfills are uh that uh that
there's a high enough chance of getting
a landf a brown field that is going to
work for a landfill that it needs that
it should be put into law that we that
that should be looked at I think that uh
one of the things that's an issue with a
lot of the brownfields is that they many
of of them are cited along rivers which
basically knocks them out from
consideration for so for
landfills uh and uh the so I think that
um we we may want cons to consider other
legislation that would encourage the use
of brownfields for other productive uh
uses like you know solar uh solar Farms
or um you know something that is also
that is compatible with it not being a
pure site but uh I think that it I think
that it's enough of a non-starter for
landfills that we should itl this bill
and if we want to do if people want to
do something else with brownfields then
propose other legislation for it and I
would be happy to co-sponsor something
with you on that representative speak I
I don't want to I don't want to do the
I'm not sure that I want to sign up for
figuring out what that something is but
but I would be willing to support it
okay as would I um represent
comto thank you madam chair and this is
not about the bill it is about the site
there were a lot of abbreviations uh
when we were looking at the brown Fields
whether it was um uh like lust and um
you know asbest and things like that and
I was just wondering if you could give
us a kind of like a list to tell us what
those different um abbreviations meant
so that we understand it and the other
question I had was some of them said
closed some of them some terminated and
I'd like to know what the qualifications
of what that means if if you don't
mind may I yeah can she sure yeah
absolutely and thank you for staying and
being here no problem we appreciate it I
think I didn't quite hear hear
everything you said some of them said
closed and some of them said what
terminated and some of them are still
open I believe that's what I saw on the
website so when I was looking at the
Brownfield sites you know you had a lot
of
abbreviations and we didn't understand
when we were looking at them this
morning kind of what some of them meant
you know what those abbreviations were
sure and how do you determine if
something is closed um or is it opened
is or completed right so closed and
completed are two different things um
does completed mean they met all the
remediation requirements clo I mean so
we just trying to get some guidance on
the terminology on that site so that we
could understand it better and interpret
the data
better y but I asked representative
kraton next sure okay s
didn't he he's sitting here looking very
dejected on Valentine's Day
crushed no I
so in fact I had a unique thought but it
was super Saed by everyone else first of
all I agree with representative kulon
that the Brownfield site should be
used but uh Dees very eloquently said
yesterday a
handful to a few to nothing and so the
idea that as representative Bixby said
that we would then tell a company to
look at something that we know is not
going to amount to anything then I don't
know why we would do that but if there
is something we could do with those
brown s Brownfield sites then I'm all in
yeah representative Murray yes thank you
now sorry um so I I think more to my
point too I did I agree I I'd like to
learn a little bit more I did look at um
what I interpreted to be on the
brownfields website to be a list of
maybe five or six that seem to have
completed their full brownfields
remediation um and but it was not a list
of many and the the acreage was small um
but then there were others that to
representative comos Point had under
project types they were listed as um
cercla versus um like a spill which I
imagine is a hazardous spill of some
site but so we're looking for clarity
there
um yes and so and how often those get
updated was also something that I was
curious about because some of the dates
went back to like there was a note that
it said oh 2015 or how often those get
Revisited um I'm challenged because I'm
not looking at exactly what you're
looking at and when I look at this
information it's in our database what
what you see online pulls from our
database and that's why you're seeing
those acronyms uh because our fields in
our database are short so lust is a
funny acronym that means leaking
Underground storage tank so that's a
site that at some point in time had an
underground tank for petroleum that
leaked it just stuck out it's
Valentine's it sounds more exciting
than is is representative
Duty would it be possible to use this
bill for interim study and basically
instead of just taking out the land
fields and just studying Brown Fields
because it seems to me like we or
somebody and I don't think we can push
this off on
Dees we need more information on the
brownfields that are out there so we
might be able to make a recommendation
or talk about it for legislation so
would that be possible well instead of
an interim study I I would actually like
to have Dees come in and do a
presentation about brownfields in New
Hampshire and um the programs that they
have for um um
brownfields what how they are perhaps
promoting to the public the use of
brownfields are there programs that help
fund um re reuse or repurposing of those
properties um I think that would be a
really interesting presentation to have
for the
committee representative Duty yeah um as
an addition to that as it turn turns out
I I think it's probably a brown field in
New in Nashville which is very small my
neighbor happens to own it and uh and
it's been capped so Dees has been
involved in it and it's it's been capped
and it's right along the the salmon and
one of the issues that we have is that
he would like to donate it to the city
but the city doesn't want to take on
quote that liability for a capped uh
Brownfield so if we could have I I need
to get more information about that to
try to elay the city's concerns because
we would like to keep that area open you
know for the Waterway but so if you
could include that something like that
uh the longevity what are the chances of
them leaking how do you monitor that
that would really be helpful to
me yes and the property that you speak
about might be a candidate for a
brownfields covenant that sometimes can
elay the concerns of an entity that's
acquiring the property it would have to
be eligible and there are criteria but
um we have a
new uh new supervisor of our brownfields
program she's an engineer who's been
with the program for many years and
she's very Dynamic and I would love to
have her come and talk with you okay
we'll have to set a date and time for
that I would I would really appreciate
that because uh it's an important issue
of how we can repurpose these um sites
for something useful in our communities
representative Howard just um when that
presentation comes is is there any sort
of documentation that you already have
of of you know like that tells that
would tell us about the individual the
thing whatever research you have on it
on the different Brown fields that would
that you could compile and bring to us
so that if we were to advance a bill we
would we could talk about the different
kinds of
landfills I'll see what we have I I
don't think we would have anything
comprehensive um that summarizes every
site we may have documents that have
success stories about Key
Properties yeah representative comto
thank you madam chair and representative
um Howard on their site you can see all
the brown Fields um and and you can send
the link out to you in an email and you
can sort them by town if you'd
like also show the
on some of them it
does representative Haskins thank you
can we hang on to the bill until we hear
this
presentation uh not I don't think so
okay because
um yeah we I don't think we'll have time
for any presentations until probably
after March okay and we really need to
get these bills
out so representative
kulon oh yeah just to clarify my initial
point I meant to uh study it to
completely remove the landfill part
because I just think I think it's
reasonable to have people um you know to
suggest a first option for say a solar
site like if there's a part on a river
that's south facing that's a perfect
place for a solar array to go as opposed
to a green field so whatever we do is
fine I'm just saying I think it's I
think it's a good
idea well I think I I don't know that we
could amend this bill to do that in the
time frame that we're looking at um but
I again I I would invite a a new bill to
be put in next year which I would be
happy to help
with uh yeah represent Bixby yeah so I
think that um just in terms of uh
figuring out what do we want to do with
this bill rather than what we want to do
with brownfields um it looks like there
are two options one would be to do an
interim study one would be to do an itl
and if we itl we still have the option
of doing an ad hoc uh study of
brownfields and committee and I would I
would prefer that latter option I would
as well representative um ger and then
Howard thank you very much uh uh so I I
I would like and perhaps an ad hoc
committee is is the way to do this for
us to have the opportunity to hear from
some more from Dees that would be great
but also I remembered and I was just
looking it up that last year in Keen uh
you we got a million-dollar Grant uh
Through The madok Economic Development
Corporation for the development of a
couple of Brownfield sites in Keane that
was disappointed that one near kind of
near I I live unfortunately didn't end
up on the list because I think it would
be ultimately for some housing but um so
I I think there are some other groups in
the state for example The madok Economic
Development Corporation there must be
others who are actively involved in this
case in using Federal money to uh work
on some of her Brownfield site so I
don't know if it's through the ad hoc
committee or some other kind of
instrument but I think it would be
helpful to hear from some of these
groups in the state that are actively
right now engaged in helping to
rehabilitate Brownfield sites okay
representative Howard I have sort of a
technical question I I support the itl
so this is this may be moot but um if we
were to put something like a landfill on
top of a Brownfield site wouldn't we be
worried about pushing the pollution
that's in there down into into that was
that was um excuse me so a question that
had come up during the hearing um
whereby somebody was I think it was
representative gerana who might have
brought that up who said that if we're
putting a landfill on top of a brown
field aren't we sort of making the
toxicity even worse first of all and
would we then also have difficulties in
monitoring it going forward because you
don't know whatever stuff is coming out
in lee8 or whatever else if it's from
the original Brownfield or from the
landfill that you put there so it
complicates matters representative Bixby
yeah so we actually have kind of an
example of this uh because the uh
current landfill in Bethlehem was put on
a previous landfill site and the
condition of doing that of them doing
that landfill was to remove a certain
amount of the of the contaminated soil
that was uh sort of underneath where
they were going to be putting the liner
and then put that into the the newly
lined landfill and that got rid of some
of it but in fact what it it also buried
a bunch of other you know more of it
which is now leeching out
into uh the towards the amusic uh and
depending on who's testing you look at
it's either you know going in at higher
levels or lower levels but there's
definitely pasas that is coming and
um I forget what the other one is maybe
dioxine that's that is leeching from
underneath the landfill in in
Bethlehem uh and because it was
essentially a Brownfield site that got
then put under a landfill so yes that is
in fact a real
problem any other discussion about HB
1132 looks like we're probably um
looking at it Ling that bill and um and
working on on some kind of legislation
to encourage uh use of of brownfields
for other purposes representative Penza
I know I'm coming in at the end and I
had briefly spoken with representative
kulon about this so that time frame
doesn't allow for us to make any
modifications to that for other uses we
just don't have I mean if you want to
take a stab at it I I certainly would
welcome it but I think I think this in
this really deserves us looking at it
more closely and if we have an ad hoc
Committee just like we're going to do
with studying food um you know the food
issues uh food safety issues um I think
I think we would come out with a better
Bill product in the end some kind
something that we could propose for next
year okay all right thank you so much
yep all right let's move on to HB 11170
requiring public benefit on community
impact assessment from the Department of
Environmental
Services do I have anyone who has a
comment on that representative Murray uh
thank you madam chair I did have a
parliamentary question I just wanted to
make sure um there are two potential
amendments and in the process of
thinking about them if we were to move
one before the other um I correct me if
I'm wrong Peter does one supersede the
other if we do something with if if we
if we work with these amendments we need
to rewrite both of them so that they are
into one Amendment because the committee
can only have one Amendment
correct represent ger um I'm trying to
remember um Dees understandably only got
the Amendments uh yeser why everybody
did but was only able to first look at
them yesterday and my recollection is
that they said they wouldn't be able yet
to to provide as much feedback on the
content of those amendments so I I
actually thought we weren't going to do
that today for that reason but so I was
just surprised well we could no we could
still just have our own conversation
about you know our thoughts on it okay
and um I mean um let me just take a look
here
just the the purpose of this work
session is not to figure out the the
complete solution this is just to figure
out the general feeling of the committee
in terms of this is is this something we
want to move on with is this something
we want to just it uh do we need to do
amendments and then we can figure out
who's doing the
Amendments well personally um I think
that um
expressing public benefit what public
benefit
means um is something that is preferable
is something that we need to do we need
to have that discussion and I think it
needs to be spelled out because um
otherwise it just seems to be this vague
kind
of whatever it is public benefit for one
person could mean public benefit
different from somebody else's
interpretation and I think if we do
start talking about what public benefit
is um it's going to be
helpful my problem was with how to
quantify some of these things um because
it's one thing yeah you can you can
measure no noise you can measure odor
you can measure how much traffic goes in
and out um you can measure different uh
metrics for groundwater pollution and
that kind of thing but there are other
there are other aspects that may be
harder to
quantify and so I I think you know we
need to kind of take a look at that a a
little closer but
um I I don't I don't have a problem with
with trying to identify what public
benefit means representative ktoa we'll
go around uh thank you madam
chair I
understand why this bill was
introduced however what really concerned
me was that this bill was kind of like a
stepping stone and the prime sponsor
said that she would hope that these
would be included in every aspect of
life
and we have seen in agriculture how
things like this adversely affect
farmers um you know we the old adages is
uh you have a uh pig farm people build
houses and then they hate the smell and
they try and get remove the
farm you know so if you define public
benefit
who who do we look to for the benefit is
it the farmer or the people the new
neighborhood that just moved in I mean I
think these are things that we really
really need to be concerned
about so I just want to make sure that
as we're looking at this that from an
agricultural standpoint we need to take
into
consideration what road we've all we've
already been down um in regards to this
I mean we just introduced a bill last
year as a noise ordinance because
farmers were having difficulty with
zoning ordinances in their towns because
they couldn't properly start their
equipment to
spray lay pesticides or do something on
their farm when they were trying to be
in compliance with the
law so please be when we do this let's
be very
cautious in how we look at
this okay I'm gonna go around this way
so Duty
first okay um thank you um yeah I agree
with what you have said I I think we
have to look at public benefit I think
we also got comments um that it needs to
be Quantified I think uh representative
Kat you know it says it's uh only
relates to Dees permits so I don't think
that that would affect Farms but I but I
could be wrong uh so I would really like
to see this go to interim study and
really see how we could flesh out uh
something that works because I think
what we've heard today and what I've
seen in Nashville with the ashal plant
is people do not feel that their
concerns about broader
environmental aspects uh are being taken
into consideration because the
permitting is also only focused on
technical so I would recommend I would
vote for interim study okay
representative Howard thank you um I I
agree with uh representative dsy um
about the interim study and I one of my
concerns is that this is um it's a
little Loosey Goosey and you know it
talks about a demonstration you you talk
about quantifying they're talking about
demonstr demonstrating and I think it's
important that that these um that the
the benefits are are taken into consider
I think that I think there's a big
difference between a pig farm and and a
a landfill so
um so I I hope that we will do interm
study and that we will um tighten up the
language quite a bit okay representative
ger yeah you yes thank you and and I
think that studying it it further is
important um I want to say that the the
idea about you know the statement which
I understand represent Thomas made
yesterday about wanting to see this be a
kind of a larger practice again begins
with a discussion that was around things
like air
permitting uh dealing with permits to do
with water Etc so uh it was it was
specific to those permits that Dees
gives to companies who are uh again
needing air permits uh water quality
permits Etc so it wasn't meant to be
this expansive comprehensive seeing it
for absolutely everything but what
happened was when when we met with
director whim uh they explained to us as
Dees did uh yesterday right that you're
looking at uh 88 different fields that
are permitted 130 or 180 I forget what
it was number of individual permits uh
in lots of different places in RSA so uh
we decided to choose specifically
landfills because we thought that this
was a place where we had a good chance
to uh come up with a narrowly
defined um uh um set of parameters and
these are practices and this is
something if we go to interim study that
will come out these are things that the
federal government does all the time and
has since the Reagan Administration net
public benefit has been a practice in
the evaluation of government projects
for practically my entire lifetime so
we're not Reinventing the wheel here um
I I think the one thing that's to me
really important is that when we talk
about net public benefit that there has
to be a requirement on applicants to
also address possible harm we can't
expect communities who don't have the
economic resources to pay somebody to do
comprehensive studies to determine these
things we're talking about companies who
will make very good living um with an
operation in a community and they should
have to be able to demonstrate that the
it meets a need and that in the end it
will do more harm than good so I agree
that further study of of how we Define
that what the metrics are that makes
sense to me but there's not one single
one of us who ever makes a decision by
just considering the benefits any
decision any of us ever make is a cost
benefit analysis you never make a
decision without having to balance out
potential disadvantages with potential
advantages and that's what our system
does right now it doesn't Define benefit
actually very well even after the
Supreme Court decision there's there's
no specific metric for public benefit
and we're defining benefit without
contrasting it with disadvantage which
as I said is literally illogical it is
not a decision-making process that any
of us ever use for anything in our lives
so I I hope that we can try to find a
way to come up with a solution that says
net public benefit is to be determined
by a comparison of benefits and possible
disadvantages I so in terms of if if
this does get voted inum study which
I've been in favor of I think that we
can have our Environmental Policy
subcommittee look at this along with the
uh amendments that have been
suggested and um and give a thorough
study of exactly part of what
representative germanus says and you
know taking all of the testimony into
consideration um and the I don't know
just as a refresher of who's on the um
Environmental Policy subcommittee we
have representative Bixby as chair um
representative brulard ktoa Penza Duty H
Haskins Howard um there's veral on there
too but we can probably have him
replaced by someone so anyway uh just as
a refresher go ahead and represent coma
thank you I agree that interim study is
a good thing and the reason I brought up
agriculture into this is because the
prime sponsor said she wanted it to be
in everything so I just wanted to uh
make us
aware okay representative Bixby yeah so
um I agree with representative gerana
that uh there needs to be an assessment
or of both potential harms and potential
benefits in uh determining public
benefit and I also agree that uh we
can't figure out figure this out in the
next four weeks
so it should be inter room study okay
representative
Murray thank you madam chair and I to
the point that that represent com was
making I just want to make sure that I I
think I just want to say that I think
the intent and and maybe representative
gerana spoke to this a little bit from
the the uh one of the co-sponsors was to
ensure that we were making sure that
things like uh industrial polluters
impacts to communities never happens
again and I really think that
in in those types of instances where my
own two communities that I represent um
have borne the consequences of
industrial pollution I think that that
was what the members intent was trying
to get
at and I see representative Thomas there
I just want to let you know in this
committee when we do something as
interim study it's not death With
Dignity we actually do study something
okay
so please know
that please do so you're invited to do
so a question can I say before she
addresses
that real quick my intent for that
question was specific to what we're
talking about like a Senco Bane th those
types of big huge projects it would
never have been you know a carp launch
and I knew what your answer meant so I
just wanted you to know I knew you
didn't mean it for like for every
entity right we were we're talking about
permits that are specific to Dees
specific with my history of my town
being uh contaminated by St gobain um I
am not aware of any permits that farmers
have um and you know I I do know that
people get upset with with noisy
roosters so there is a noise problem but
um that's not I it was it was the Aging
hippie in me that that
wants that wants justice for all you
know so that's what I was I was not
saying that public benefit has to be
done for absolutely everything because
that's not logical so it was I take full
responsibility for that again it's it's
the idealist in me but I was not saying
when I when I implied that it was little
off the cuff did not imply that it
should be applied to everything thank
you I would love it here I am getting
into trouble again I would love it if
you could consider people first and
profit second that's that's
all representative Katon okay all right
anybody else have any comment on uh HB
1170 thank you okay um let's see HB 1620
relative to suspending the issuance of
new landfill permits until
2031 do we have any comments about that
representative kulong uh yeah I have
some concerns on this bill specifically
with the year 2031 I'm a little bit
worried that the sponsor of the bill
threw a dart at a calendar and it landed
on 2031 and that's the reason why and I
haven't heard any like seeing any data
or seeing any evidence or anything
suggesting why the year should be 2031
so does anybody have an objection to
having a pause on um permitting in the
state representative
coma thank you madam chair
um I think that there may come to light
some more
information um with the solid working
group um I was having a discussion today
that gave me pause for concern which I I
didn't even know about um however we
heard a lot of other bills
today that if
we limited any new
landfill and subjected them to a
percentage of out ofate
waste that might be a way to go um just
because really the the whole idea of
either doing a pause or whatever is to
limit out of state
waste so my that would be my question
representative
ger thank you uh I just want to say
first of all 2031 wasn't arbitrary the
point is that according to the solid
waste management report 2034 is the
earliest date at which we could begin to
see a capacity issue so 2031 was picked
to be three years ahead of that time so
that there would be lead time between
the end of the pause and when we might
see capacity issues uh the bill also
includes the stipulation that we that
Dees could continue to do the
investigations for permitting to that
point right so that it wouldn't be just
putting a an absolute pause on the
entire process um so I just wanted to
clarify those things and I don't know if
it's possible and I agree representative
comad just made an excellent point about
other bills that we have that would
solve these problems um and uh so I
don't know if it's possible to consider
retaining this bill uh because we don't
oh no because it's the second year
second year okay well that answers that
question thank you representative Bixby
yeah so um I think that uh having some
sort of a pause makes sense uh I think
that um we heard that uh there is a a
cycle time for uh what it takes to
propose and get a new per new landfill
permitted that would would be longer
than that three years between uh 2031
and
2034 um I would just uh throw out there
that perhaps we would make want to make
that pause until maybe 2028 so that we
are able to see what the results of the
bill the other bills we're working on
right now uh are and then uh that and
then new permits could be issued in the
light of the new thing of the bills that
that are working through right the
process right
now representive kulon yes so I just
want to be clear like my number one
concern is the price and the price like
the area that I represent we have all
private waste and the price has gone up
when I asked it when I asked the
economic question you know I got a
question I got an answer that was like
well yeah prices could go up for you
know fuel costs to go into a different
site all these different answers and
then the fiscal note says indeterminable
increase so it seems like the fiscal
note is actually correct on this bill um
so yeah if we could adjust the date that
would make it or the year that would
make it a little bit more amenable I
think represent
Penza was this the bill where the
gentleman came and spoke about the
fiscal note I I yes yeah okay yeah
um so it's to me I think what he said
was really impactful I think he covered
that clearly because this really
wouldn't have it couldn't have any
impact so if prices are going to
increase this it won't have anything to
do with this moratorium Bill I'm in full
support of this bill I think we don't
have a capacity issue um if we if you
know the Committees for taking off a
couple years it's fine but I believe
that the testimony that was given was
like so powerful especially 19 years of
not being able to figure this out I've
only been here a year I get it but it's
unbelievable that all you know and I
know that there's people that have been
here a lot longer and they you know
we're churning through these things and
and I think the time is now I think
we're ready um and I think the time has
been here for a while but um I know that
um I know that people my constituents
are are wanting something as well and um
you know I I feel like I have more skin
in the game I have there's a landfill
that is you know uh three miles down the
road from where I live so um and I just
have to say that the conversations that
I've had with the folks that um run our
landfill are are fantastic they're open
they're honest they're transparent um
and and those are the things where I I
they're
they can't come out and speak on
something like this but if they could um
I believe that they would support this
because there needs to be worked done
and we all know that there
does represent Murray yeah thank you
madam chair um one of the things that
I'm thinking about really intentionally
is how many irons we have in the fire
this year around solid waste and I feel
like um we had two days of testimony
just now on landfilling and um when
we're talking
[Music]
about other policies that are sort of
influx as well as um what we're looking
at
with um the potential pause on issuance
of permits and I think that that's the
key factor here nothing is uh suggesting
that we stop with the process that is
continuing away it's just we're pressing
pause on issuing any new ones until we
get a better sense of like
representative Bixby said where some of
these things are going and I I don't
know what representative ktoa had sort
of intimated at with regard to Solid
Waste working group but I would is I is
that what you
sorry yeah so I had a uh conversation
with um representative eel and um
believe it was
Steve POI out in the hallway um and I do
believe Steve's going to be coming to
your committee on
on March 6 to discuss further um so
yeah go ahead
represent uh thank you ma'am yeah I I
just really like what representative R
just said the I'm sitting here looking
and so you're you're talking about
reducing inate to 15% you're talking
about a seven-year moratorium you're
talking about a rules committee that is
changing rules and then you know
continually upgrading those for the next
3 months and so there just there's a lot
of churn
so I'm just I don't want to break
anything in our haste to fix everything
and we're doing a lot of fixing and to
figure out because all that is based on
assumption there's assumption there's
analysis but no one has a crystal ball
so I would be in favor of a pause I
would say 27 instead of 28 but I'm not
going to fall on my sword on that I just
think we do need to just make sure that
what we're doing is having the intended
effect and not breaking other things
over representative NAB thank you madam
chair um I mean I agree we have a lot of
irons in the fire but we also don't have
control of the outcome of all these
bills right we can only do what we can
do so I don't see a a real conflict with
some of these landfill bills I also
think if the permanent process is on
average 6 to 10 years that having a
pause till 2030 is 6 years from now it's
not really that far in the future and if
we're allowing landfill permitting the
process to still continue it doesn't
ultimately hinder a company that is
trying to site a new
landfill so all I have to say thank you
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair I think the reason why we have all
these landfill bills is because we're
waking up to what's going on in our
state and I think people care
desperately about what we are going to
do about this problem and it's a
multifaceted problem for sure and the
out ofate waste bill doesn't answer the
question about the fact that Dees is
trying to write rules review an
application at the same time which
frankly to me never made sense so I do
think we need to pause I guess the bill
says they can review it I don't really
know what that means but they can't
issue the permit at least until we
settle some of these issues and make
some delineation about public benefit
and public harm yeah and out ofate trash
and all the rest so I I see them as
distinct they're a lot and it's a lot of
work for us I'm willing to do my share
of the work it matters greatly to me so
I I hope that we do get the
pause okay representative Howard
thank you madam chair um I I agree with
uh representative H Haskins I think that
um that a pause will give us time to
sort these other things out and it's it
it it's five or seven years whichever
date we pick is nothing compared to the
forever of these chemicals that are
leaking into our um into our at our
environment so I think that um you know
if if a permit came to Dees or whatever
yeah Dees um that said that had the
solution for forever chemicals if they
said we want to build a land landfill
and we know exactly what to do about
about the Le Lee it um then I would say
yes let's let's permit it right away but
we don't have that and the and what they
leave behind or what they enter into our
environment is is much more longterm
than what they would have to wait to to
put their to get their permit approved
represent
kulon uh yeah I think life in America
has changed drastically in the past five
years and I also think Dees is capable
of multitasking so this idea that like
we need to stop the permits so this
other stuff can be done I mean d manages
to come here and talk about bills and
trash goes to the landfill it all kind
of still happens so uh I can support the
bill if the year changes not to be 2031
because I feel like that's uh
irresponsible
honestly
any other well let's let's talk about
what year we would be comfortable with
because ultimately if we're going to
make an amendment to this bill I think
that that the year is going to be um
something that would be the
negotiating notion so um give us a give
us a thought I would agree with
representative bixby's 28 I was going to
say I agree with representative Katon
[Laughter]
27 so
we well we say
25 i' I'd be I'd be a minable to 2028
myself um so that's not me no oh thank
God did you say I'm sorry 2028 I'd be
okay with
2028 anybody else yes
no all
right so so does anybody want to um go
to OSS with that
date you would okay sure all right well
I guess um that's
uh yeah okay so
um and so I guess our our next what we
have coming up I just misplaced my paper
oh well um so we have coming up next
week
um I have planned for Tuesday morning
from 10: to 11: in the
morning um to exec
bills excuse me we've already discussed
HB 1386 which um someone's working on an
amendment for that
1386 that's um the lithium ion battery
oh yeah no we already have an amendment
from representative eel on that bill um
and
uh so from in the morning we're going to
be executing some
bills uh HB
1376 would be on that as well relative
to prohibiting certain packaging from
carrying the recycling
logo um HB
1681 relative to the sale of products
labeled as biodegradable or
compostable um
hp504 will be going to a subcommittee so
that's not on our list of um bills to be
exact HP
1687 uh relative disposal of
construction and demolition debris which
representative Murray's working on an
amendment HB 1132 which we discussed
just now
um HB yes HB
1170 which is the public benefit which
uh we are going to do um I guess an
study
on and and uh hb1 1620 which uh we just
said we would do an amendment so those
are the bills that we're planning on uh
executing and then uh we would have a
work session on the bills that we heard
today HB
1221 HB 1145 and HB
1632 then we'll have three hearings in
the afternoon um we will be done with
our landfill bills and we will be moving
on to animal bills so we'll be talking
about prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive ra uh based rodent traps uh
relative to allowing private ownership
of oh the the kangaroo
Bill and then h505 establishing an
animal abuse offender registry so th
that's what's on the docket for Tuesday
February 20th and know we meeting
Wednesday also we are meeting Wednesday
also to do a work session on those three
bills that were going to hear on Tuesday
plus we are going to hear four more
bills uh one uh relative to co-ownership
of dogs I've reached out to the judicial
the AG's office regarding
um what happens with co-ownership of of
animals if there's you know maybe an
issue having to do with the bill with
that and um so I've spoken to somebody
about that I'm waiting to hear back um
then we also in the afternoon would be
talking about relative to disp
disposition of vicious dogs then the
bill repealing the requirement to
register dogs annually and then relative
to exemptions from the rabies vaccine so
February 21st will be dog
day but we're not in the dog days of su
okay and with that I want to thank
everybody for um all the work you guys
have been doing um the tedious hours to
listening and sitting patiently asking
questions really good questions by the
way and um just having these
conversations and working through some
things represent Bixby okay so on a
slightly different topic I um ran into
Henry vo who is the uh um uh uh lobbyist
who works with waste management and um
mentioned the possibility of doing a
committee field trip later in the spring
uh to uh to TurnKey and on Waste
Management also has a murf in Northern
Massachusetts so uh he said that they
would be able to do arrange a t a field
trip for both turny and uh and to the
murf um so that uh we could get to see
what those two types of facilities look
like uh so I think that's something the
dates haven't been nailed down yet but
um that's something to look forward to
after we finish our
bills we're a jour